didn't ask anything. I read you a quote of yourself that you
would set out loud. And I said, "Do you still stand by that?"
Even though it's factually
>> If Lance was just median IQ, he could actually make
it as a YouTuber, like in a Hassan type of way. All he had to
do is be median IQ. He could just hit the median, he would have
been fine. He didn't have to be worldbeating smart. He just had
to be average. >> Where a kid walk. >> But then I
I saw this before like really reconnecting with how dumb he is
and I was like, "Wait, this guy's kind of a gigachad." I didn't
even realize he's like actually kind of a gigachad. And you would
never know it cuz he says the dumbest things like in the dumbest
way. I just I thought he was like ugly fetus looking ass. I mean
that side that side profile is like a good-look guy there
es and flows. All right. The last thing I've got tonight is access
to >> this Jesse Singal debate. Oh, right. I I remember
why I clicked into this. Dude, am I the only person like I've
never felt like I can't judge somebody's looks. Um, or sorry,
I've never felt like I'm I have a difficult time judging somebody's
looks. Usually pretty like uh disconnected from reality. Somehow
I thought Lance was like super ugly because of how dumb he is.
But then I I saw this before like really reconnecting with how
dumb he is and I was like, "Wait, this guy's kind of a gigachad.
I didn't even realize he's like actually kind of a gigachad."
And you would never know it because he says the dumbest things
like in the dumbest way. I just I thought he was like ugly fetus
looking ass. I mean that side that side profile look like a good-look
guy there. You see his debate with Lauren Southern about mass
graves. No, I didn't. I'm sure he could have that up. By the
way, Lauren Southern was right about that just to be clear. So
dim lowers his riz. It really does. Okay, let's see how he prefaces
this and then we'll go through this. I'm not really like big
on the literature around trans stuff, so we'll see how we go
through it. I can't imagine it's going to go well. I know a lot
of people reacted to this that it's like good content. So, I
haven't seen it at all. >> Hey everybody, I've got the
Jesse Singal debate coming up right away. But >> also,
I'm going to grab some water in the meantime here. I'm going
to grab some water and we'll go through it.
>> Give me
the preamble and I completely understand. You can click on this
point in the time code. I just want to clear up a couple things.
I was originally going to upload this debate on Monday, right
after it took place, but Jesse actually asked me if I would wait
until Thursday, which is why you see in social media posts me
saying certain things like, "Hey, the, you know, the the debate
will be up on YouTube uh on Thursday." That kind of stuff. And
then I just recently found out that he went ahead and uploaded
it anyway. So, I mean, here we are. And in addition, >> that'd
be pretty scummy by Jesse if that happened. I don't know why
that would happen. That debate was so bad. Oh, are you talking
about the Tim one or some people are talking about the Timool
one. Oh, the mass grave. Oh, it was a part of the tide turning
on the whole mass graves narrative. You're asking about the Lord
and Southern one again. I >> into that. I noticed that
he also in his, you know, introduction on the podcast episode
talks about how in the Zoom version, like he recorded the Zoom
call and put a link to the Zoom call, I guess, in the description.
Uh, there might be a part at the very end of the debate that
can confuse some people. So, I wanted to clear that up right
away. I found out that Jesse wanted to debate me and had actually
been trying to entice me using the Palestinian Children's Relief
Fund uh as I guess some kind of like you wouldn't turn down this
valuable charity, would you? Which to be honest, I found kind
of gross. So, I emailed him to the effect of like I've wanted
to debate Jesse Singal for a really long time. You don't need
terms and conditions. I mean, if you want to donate money to
a worthwhile charity, that's entirely up to you. But in the meantime,
yeah, I I have absolutely no problem coming on to your show.
I just simply wasn't aware that you had been posting on Blue
Sky. It's just one of those things like the minute I found out
I like you know looked up his email and immediately contacted
him and that's where I thought that was going to be but then
at the very end of the debate he ended up bringing that up and
saying so per our terms we agreed to both you know donate $1,000
to uh the Palestinian Children's Relief Fund and again it was
just one of those strange awkward moments where I was like I
didn't know if that was intentional or why he was doing that.
Now, he does say in his podcast that he actually got that wrong,
and he did. And so, that's, you know, I guess a good correction,
but the fact that he left that in his unedited version, uh, made
me want to actually address that. One of the biggest problems
right now is actually getting life-saving aid into that part
of the world specifically because of the blockade that Israel
is imposing upon Palestinians. So, there are GoFundMes to families,
so you can actually directly help support them materially. I'm
personally donating to a bunch of them. So, I'll include the
links in the description of this video. >> Thank you for
taking the time to join me. Do you want to quickly tell uh our
audience a little bit about who you are? >> Uh yeah, my
name is Lance. I'm a uh I suppose comedian from uh Canada who
covers news, politics, tries to make it entertaining, but like
most people who spend a lot of time on the internet, uh obviously
waste a little bit too much of my life on slob and other brain
rotting
>> As do we all. Uh yeah, so this I explained in the intro,
but this uh talk came about because you know, you were somewhat
critical of me uh and some of the stuff I've written and said
about youth gender medicine. And Katie and I have found that
often when people uh criticize us, they're unwilling to then
not have a conversation. So >> I'm back. I'm back. I'm
back. Okay. Was I the only one who got the impression there that
Lance just didn't want to give $1,000?
that like he felt off because because Jesse was like asking him
to donate $1,000. He's like, "Oh, I thought I got out of that.
I thought I got out of that." Oh, god damn it. That That's the
impression I got with Lance talking there. Well, maybe not. This
guy's painfully
That's very rude. That's a very rude thing to point out, Germanmanium
G. It's a very rude accurate thing to point out. That's up. I
appreciate that. I'm going to let you sort of uh take the reigns
here. I will say to your audience, there was a miscommunication.
I didn't expect this to be video. I look a little bit haggarded
from uh Fourth of July drinking and uh little bit of illness,
so be merciful. But uh other than that, take it away. >> Yeah.
So, uh I obviously have some pretty strong critiques of your
work. >> He's visibly question mark. No, >> no, that's
a horrible thing to say. Deranium, I'm going to have to time
you out. Okay, that was gross. I don't know why you made that
comment. That was really disgusting. I totally disavow that comment.
and uh you know, I'm quite excited to have the opportunity to
bring them up in person. Uh I figured we'd use the infamous article
that you published in The Atlantic, the cover story when kids
say they're trans, kind of as a jumping off point. Uh so we can
go through it. >> And I'm pretty sure you'll probably hear
a lot of these critiques before, but >> shockingly, a lot
of people think that's like the nose that they're saying that.
To me, it's the hair. The hair is like the dead giveaway. The
like very curly hair. I went through the article uh again and
reread the entire thing and wanted to kind of just break down
each piece of it. And in the article uh obviously you spoke to
a lot of people who had dransitioned uh including Claire, Max
Robinson, Carrie Ste. >> So they're talking about an actual
article that he's written. Um maybe we can pull this article
up as we go. >> Kellahan and Delta. And uh for about the
first 9,000 words of the piece, uh there's not really a single
example of a welladjusted or happy transerson who had gone through
the process. Uh obviously the examples that you use starting
with Claire, for example, uh you
is that so correct me if I'm wrong. Is that not an argument
that Emma Vigland made? I believe Emma Vigland screamed this
at Jesse on a call with Sam Cedar, Emma, and Jesse, right? I
believe I believe she screamed that at him like, "You didn't
you didn't say anything for 9,000 words." And it's like, "Well,
it's a 25,000word article, isn't it?" It's like a massive profile.
So, it's like, "Yeah, like building my premise, which is we're
we're speeding along Youth Gender Medicine way too fast. Obviously,
I'm going to hook people. Obviously, I'm a writer. I'm trying
to hook people into the article. I'm giving them like the premise
of the article. Yes. >> Often invoke the fact that they
had been suffering from depression. Um, and that you believe
or at least the testimonies are leading you to believe that this
has something to do with outside influences that had somehow
impacted their decision to want to transition in the first place.
Is that fair?
>> Yeah. I mean, I will say you're I think you're lifting
that language almost directly from Slate. Uh, as the way Slate
put it was, as the piece goes on, notably without a single happy,
welladjusted trans scene among its host of central characters.
Oh, that is that is like a brutal response to Dude, I do this
sometimes, okay? If I'm talking to somebody on stream and I see
a chatter make a comment and then I hear the person on stream
repeat that chatter's comment, I will just address the chatter
directly. And I think that's the funniest thing to do. It's like,
hey, you I know you don't have like a internal monologue over
there. You can't think for yourself. you have no no spark of
intelligence. So, I'll just address the chatter who gave you
that argument and we'll continue on with our lives. >> Characters
for the first 9,000 plus >> Which is really really hypocritical
of me because sometimes if I see a funny joke that a chatter
made, I'll take it I'll take it shamelessly and never cite them.
Okay, >> we'll continue. >> There there's a lot of
trans adults uh cited further up in the story, but because of
the structure of the story, yeah, I think it's trans adults.
Uh I wouldn't call Delta like a full-blown dransitioner. I'd
call her a desister. But yeah, I think some of the dransitioners
are higher up than the uh Orion Foss and uh there was another
kid who um was sort of a happily transitioned young person. So
yeah, in terms of the structure of it, I think that's mostly
true. >> So yeah, Slate's one of the many articles that
I had to read to basically see the uh opposing sides that have
already been broughten up in relation to you, but I wanted to
go a couple steps further. So I actually broke down each one
of their stories in words themselves, uh which that article didn't
have. So, Claire, it's 1,312 words related to her personal story.
Max Robinson, 10,086 uh words related to her personal story.
Carrie Stella, 100 words. Carrie Callahan, 530 words. Delta,
569 words. So, that's approximately 3,600 words for all of the
uh dransitioning stories. And then, uh at the very end, there's
the what are considered, I suppose, the more positive stories.
Uh Scott Padberg, which uh he him six uh sorry, 569 words. And
then Orian floss he him which is 584.
>> Okay. Sitch and Adam stretched this debate to five hours
today. I think that's how I I got it was Sitch and Adam were
watching it. Somebody saw that and they linked like it to me.
But um it is good. It's like a good debate. And there's lots
of other stuff. Trust me. You watch Lance debate, you know it's
going to be a good time. Okay.
Lance can turn anything into content. He is he is actually like
a gift to content. Unironically. He will make anything. He'll
do anything. anything he does, it can be content because he'll
make a fool of himself basically every time. >> So the
bulk of the article is dedicated to telling the stories of dransitioners
and oftentimes highlighting things uh not only that they had
suffered depression but in some cases that they had been assaulted.
In the case of Max Robinson, it talks about how she was raped
at 13 years old and then you felt necessary to include that at
14 she had watched her friend be assaulted by another man. Um
and then obviously to bring up the depression and anxiety disorder
that she experienced. Um and then in that case as well as others
such as hers and Claire's uh there's obviously
the implication that so for Max Robinson it was that she was
watching the Tyra Bank show and that she had seen a uh worker
Buck Angel uh talking about transition that influenced uh her
decision uh in Claire's case. >> Does this does he make
a literal argument for social contagion? Is that what Lance is
trying to get >> a YouTuber? uh but this seems to be a
frequent uh like theme that you were highlighting between all
of them. And I I think my big point here is that on a topic of
which the rates of transition and dransition are becoming clearer
and clearer with more and more studies that come out and obviously
in terms of dransition the rates are quite low. you chose to
focus primarily. Well, we'll get to we'll get to this part, right?
We'll get to the part. We can go back and forth and and you know,
we can talk about study after study, >> but even in the
article itself, right, you mentioned that you know, there's one
>> Wait, Buck Angel was a worker. Did Buck Angel not do
like content on the internet? I thought Buck Angel Buck Angel
I thought Buck Angel like sold stuff on the internet like pictures
and would that not qualify you as a sex worker? I don't think
there's an argument that they're a prostitute, but sex worker
in terms of selling content did. Okay. Yeah. >> One study
that referenced
rates are very low at 2%. However, we can't truly know. I I think
what you've done here is effectively use a lot of anecdotal evidence
as well as selective
uh interviews to try and highlight uh a narrative that you yourself
are trying to craft, which is that in each one of these cases,
we have people who had been influenced by outside sources. Often
times they experienced severe trauma. Uh and then for a reader
who had never or doesn't know anything about this topic, if they
come across this article and this is their introduction to trans
people and the concept of transitioning for example, they're
going to come away with a article where the vast majority and
the bulk of it really shows that this is something in which people
are either doing because of social contagions, peer pressure,
uh and potentially even uh assault or uh you know forms of depression
and anxiety.
>> Yeah, that is literally the point of the article. The
article is to say, hey, there are significant risks to transitioning
that are not be being taken seriously by the people pushing youth
gender medicine, and we need to take these risks more seriously.
Of course, an article with that basic premise is going to make
those points and is probably going to be a scary thing for anybody
who's looking to transition, especially at a young age, right?
It is literally an art article
critical of the of the practice.
Of course, that would be
Listen, you go to Cisco and Eert who give you like a review on
your on your movie or whatever, right? And you're like, "Dude,
uh, if people see this, they're just going to think my movie
without like any
Isn't it your responsibility to present how you could possibly
see my movie as good? Isn't that your responsibility?"
No, it's a critique. It is actually critique. If you think there
are disingenuous parts of the critique, you can critique those
yourself. And then you don't have to say, "Well, why you like
my article?" Also, you can just give me the critique points.
Yeah. Thank you. >> Yeah. I mean, there's sort of a point
a seven or 800word bit at the top of the story above all the
stuff you're talking about, uh, or most of it that talks about,
uh, transition working and how there's been a long history of
trans people not having access to it. So, I guess I just question
who would read the story and come away confused about my stance
on like whether some people should have access to this medicine.
Um, in I think in some cases I was a little bit sorry. >> That
wasn't my assertion. I said that you you're crafting a narrative
here for a first person or a first- time reader on this topic
who's going to walk away thinking that the majority of people
who undergo transitioning eventually do dransition because the
bulk of this is concentrating on again. >> But how would
how would that be possible when he literally gave the percentage
of dransition rate? What? Yes, you show anecdotes of people who
dransition but you say the rate is 2%.
and probably make it like a a qualifier on it. >> How would
they come to that conclusion if I don't say that? >> Oh,
because so as a journalist, and this is why I think that you
are particularly crafty what you do. It's not simply that you
need to report on facts. I think that should be just the bare
minimum, right? That you should be able to report factually on
things that that actually occur. But you are also crafting a
narrative in what you choose to report on and what you choose
to highlight and what you choose to actually bring a lot of attention
to. And in the case of your story, I would say again the overwhelming
majority is spent on people who had experienced uh severe trauma,
depression, perhaps even assault or rape uh as children and then
at which point they had chosen to dransition. Uh and you include
that in the story to kind of craft the narrative. So people reading
it will then assume that or infer it.
point. they had chosen to dransition uh sold to rape uh as children
and then at which point they had chosen to dransition uh and
you include that in the story to kind of craft the narrative.
So people >> I don't think by the way I don't even think
that's like the wouldn't it be the opposite? Wouldn't it be him
arguing
Hold on.
I I would assume that the argument here that that people who
are anti- youth youth trans medicine usually make is that assault
or early life assault child assault child trauma is what leads
people to transitioning. They they like kind of disassociate.
They kind of lose identity and they will transition at that point.
Is is that not like the actual critique you should be making
of him? Not that they like got after transitioning and then decided
to drans. people reading it will then >> I don't even know
what the order the this is. I would just assume like the general
narrative is the opposite of >> assume that or infer it.
>> Well, I think what I want people my what I was trying
to get at with the article is that this is complicated and we're
when you're talking about young people and physical transition
uh especially permanent things like hormones and I would I would
argue per puberty blockers shouldn't be considered reversible
like they have been for a while. I think I might have even called
them reversible in that I don't think that's accurate anymore.
I think it's complicated and there's a big difference between
a kid who has felt gender dysphoric their whole life and then
is approaching puberty. I think a kid like that should be handled
really differently from a kid like Max Robinson where it comes
on after a trauma and and what I've had Oh, so Lance just got
that totally wrong as well. Right. Lance doesn't even Lance didn't
even read it closely enough to know. So I just that would have
been my assumption and it seems like Jesse is correcting here
now where he's saying actually what happened was they had ault
a young childhood assault and then they decided to transition
probably we need to handle that with care that seems like a major
concern that that could be some other issue masquerading as gender
dysphoria. Oh wow. Trouble getting a straight answer from from
critics is like it seems unlikely to me that you think gender
identity exists in this sort of separate realm where it's totally
separate. um are totally detached from someone's pure influence,
from cultural influence, from trauma.
Um so to me, like if you if you read the article, you will see
some more complicated cases because that's what the article was
about. But it it shows a range of outcomes. Now, data wise, we
just we don't know uh like how many people dransition. The most
well-known researcher on this is a trans guy named Kenan McKinnon.
He says depending on the study you look at, I forget the exact
range he he gave, but it can be anything from 5 to 20%. I think
it's probably not as high as 20%. It also depends how you uh
define it. Un lance has got the fact check. 5 to 10%. Okay. >> Unfortunately,
in this article, I sort of this was seven years ago now, but
I I said dransition was rare. Uh I I don't stand by that. I think
we basically
in part because trans people since like the 1950s have
I listen I said dtrans was rare in that article. I don't stand
by that anymore. Actually dansrans is way less rare than I thought.
>> I've been getting over and not had a lot of good research
done on trans medicine. I think we don't know what the dransition
rate is especially for kids who didn't go through sort of the
normal clinical process uh of the Dutch protocol which involves
a lot of therapy a lot of talking through a lot of discussing
coorbidity. So if you have data uh setting aside the fact this
article is from 2018 if you have data showing like a reliable
dransition rate I'm all ears. I just haven't seen it. >> Okay.
If you don't mind can we get to that after this part because
I wanted to kind of compartmentalize each one of these. So, if
we're still speaking about >> I I Okay, I'm happy. >> Oh,
I by the way, I need to shill more. I I used to shill every hour
automatically, and I've not been doing that recently. I haven't
shilled at all the stream yet. Guys, if you like the content,
I want you to go ahead follow on every platform, okay? Especially
Twitter, especially Twitch, twitch.tv/jdlk
with an underscore and x.com/jlk
with an underscore. All right, you can join the Discord.
if you want to do that. Uh, pretty chill community, good vibes,
good times. All right, join the Discord. If you want to support
me monetarily, if you want to take your support a little further,
okay, then just watching. All right, what if we don't like the
content but watch anyway? Then donate anyway. Yeah, if you're
going to if you're going to sit here watch, then yeah, donate,
too. If you're if your actions and how you spend your time and
money have nothing to do with what you enjoy, then you might
as well give it all to me. Thank you. I appreciate it. I don't
know what's going on with you, but I'll take advantage. Yeah,
I'll take some money. Thank you. Thank you. All right.
is where you can get extra Discord perks, extra content, okay?
Patreon.com/jok.
Anything you anything you sign up for is substantial. Okay, you
don't even have to do any of the specific tiers. You know, you
can sub I think you can sign up for basically any amount of money.
Yeah, the $5 tier, you get soundboards in the Discord, you get
a couple other perks. Soundboards in the Discord, you get to
talk during the first hour of the stream in the Discord. There's
a couple other things. $25 tier, you get pre-stream, post stream
content. Um, I swear I'm like so close. Okay, I'm so close to
getting my life together enough that I can get more consistent
oiler content out. Right now, it's like pretty hard to get oiler
content out if I'm doing, you know, 6 to8 hours of streaming
a day as well. So, I'm but I've almost got it together. Okay,
I've almost got my [__] together enough that I can
get more consistent oiler content out. We'll see. We'll see.
We'll see. The other issue I have with that is probably the best
time for oiler content is about four hours into the stream, right?
Based on stream time. So, I think on Oiler content days, we'll
have to go live earlier so we can end earlier and then we can
do oiler content at about the the exact right time. Anyway, each
tier is for the big boys. Okay, for the big ballers, big boss
ballers. There's a couple extra perks for this. You get your
own unique icon. You get your own unique Discord color. Couple
other things. But hey, any support is appreciated. I appreciate
anything you guys can do. All right. If you want to make the
stream go longer, on the other hand, instead of just handing
me money, okay, you want to you want to pay for more content,
there's a couple ways you can do that. There's the donation links.
You can buy a TTS message. Explanation boy, donate in the chat
gives you both links. Uh, for some reason, the kickbot link didn't
show up, but it will eventually. Okay.
There's the kickbot link. $2 minimum on Kickbot, $3 minimum on
Streamlabs. You can do funny AI voices on Kickbot. You can sub
on Twitch. You could give Twitch Prime. You can sub on Kick.
You can give subs on kick. If you want to just gift money to
the stream, you want to make the stream go longer. The kick subs
are the best way to do that. This is 955 split, $5 a pop. You
can donate money to me. I get almost all of it. It's really nice.
All right. You can give subs. You can sub individually. I love
individual subs. If you don't have an individual sub on kick,
I really appreciate anybody who individually subs because it
provides me with recurring monthly revenue that I can plan around
and have a more stable like income from. All right. Five gifted
subs every once in a while is awesome. But the individual subs,
those roll over and it gives me like, oh, I'm going to make about
this much this month, no matter what, which is nice security
to have. I really appreciate it. Yeah. So, I think I got through
everything there. Um, I don't know why the kickbot link didn't
show up, but hold on. I'll I'll get that for you guys and I'll
pin that in the chat over there. Give me a second. Wait, why
is this not I don't even have my own kickbot. What? What? Should
be there, right? Should be this. Yes, it's this. Okay, there
it is. I'll pin it in the chat. $2 minimum for TTS. Wait, $3
minimum? I think $3 minimum for TTS on Kickbot. Okay. Yeah. Anyway,
thank you guys for all your support. I appreciate it. Let's continue
on with the content. That's my uh top of the hourbreak. By the
way, I just do it >> Okay. But let me let me just make
one minor complaint, which is like if your whole thing is like
I'm
>> uh disproportionately focusing on X rather than Y, and
my answer is, well, we don't know how X common is, you can you
can understand. But >> I I totally agree with you and I
I I think that's a fair thing for me to have to disprove. So
I I've got, you know, a breath of studies that I eventually wanted
to start talking about and unpacking piece by piece, but then
we move away from this topic and you actually asked the question
that could you also ask that question a little bit later as well
because I want to answer it firsthand cuz you know, anytime you're
like, I haven't seen a single one of my critics capable of answering
or responding to this, I I think that uh it's important to actually
unpack those. But maybe I it would be easier if we had a baseline
of something we can both agree with so that I could actually
try and see where the point of contention is. Would you agree
with the assertion that for example gay people were stigmatized
heavily as being potential predators and as as a way of trying
to >> Yes. They still they still are. There's been a >> Why
would that be Wait, why is that relevant to this conversation?
>> A resurgence of that. Yeah. >> And do you agree
that the majority >> Oh, that would be really smart signal.
I don't know why I don't do that. Damn. Send signal
with the amazing idea. Oh my god. Just put in a button. >> Offenders
are sis men. >> Totally do that. >> Are men uh probably
majority of >> that's the majority of people because most
offenders are male and most males are cis. Yeah, I would imagine.
Yeah. >> Okay. So granted that if I wrote an article in
which I was interviewing the victims of assault and I focused
primarily on the victims of assault who had been assaulted by
even though they were telling their stories, this actually happened
and it was 100% factually true. Do you understand then that I
would be crafting a narrative that would further stigmatize?
Wait,
>> does Lance understand that most like
>> wouldn't most like childhood child predators be men
and so like men who are assaulted as children just have a extremely
high likelihood of being assaulted by men?
Should we not hold on should we not report on those because people
might think gay people are
>> because I was focusing primarily even though they were
the minority of the offenders I was crafting a narrative that
when people read that story they would read the personal testimonies
of multiple people who had been assaulted and then walk away
from that perhaps more frightened contributing then to the stigmatization
of gay people.
So just just to make the analogy fit in this hypothetical article,
you'd also interview people who were assaulted by sis men >> by
No. Well, we're not doing sis or trans here. I'm doing or but
yes, I would I would interview say six people who had been assaulted
by and then one person who had been assaulted by
>> he's saying if he only writes about men being assaulted
by men like that's the bulk of assaults would be crafting a nerve.
I understand what he's saying. It's though because unfortunately
you might not have a lot of um you might not have anybody who's
like a FTM who has that exact story, right? Like he's got stories
that he's got for dransitioners. He happens to have seen this
and he thinks there's like uh he thinks the point he's trying
to make is if you were insulted as a child probably your transition
or your your gender dysphoria should be treated or should be
questioned in some ways that wouldn't go for everybody. Right?
That's the point he's trying to make. Unfortunately, he's going
to need people who are insulted his children to make that point.
And he's going to need like he's going to need um he's not going
to have a huge sample size. That can't be something like that's
not just crafting a narrative. That's just a small sample size.
He's just telling the story. Does he have to say, "Oh, by the
way, even though all the assaults here are by men on men, um
I don't think gay people
That's not how most people think. Just because I'm telling a
story about who broke into my house and it was a black person,
I don't think all black people are criminals. just say no.
I don't even know. Yeah, it's just it's bizarre to say it's just
crafting a narrative when this guy like doesn't actually push
that narrative anywhere else in any of his content. If he pushed
that narrative elsewhere, I could understand, but he doesn't
push that narrative anywhere, right? So, it's weird to to put
that narrative on him when he's just never pushed that narrative
and to say from one article that's relying on, you know, on anecdotes
to to try to put that narrative on him. It just doesn't make
any sense to me.
>> I mean, if you're Yeah. If your article was just about
salt and how off common it is, I would I would find that odd.
Uh I think this analogy fails for a number of reasons. One of
which is this is a pretty new medical protocol that it's been
around since >> You don't have to disagree with it with
uh or sorry, you don't have to apologize for disagreeing with
me, Twisted Rope. It's fine. It's fine. I'm just saying like
this is just uh what do you call
>> Aggressively arguing for my opinion. >> 2008ish
or you know Dutch did it a little bit earlier. Um, and we don't
know much about it. So, I think if you're writing about a new
thing where you don't know the base the base rates,
um, I also I guess I'm just confused as to what in my Atlantic
article you would find to be stigmatizing of trans people. Uh,
like what what is a quote in my article that you think, you know,
cast dispersions on trans people, the trans experience? But just
to be clear, you would agree that if I did that, that was demonstrating
that I as as the the person who was writing the article, the
the the journalist in this case was distinctly trying to push
a narrative and in order to fearmonger towards that there are
higher rates. I would disproportionately be crafting a narrative
that isn't true in doing so. Just in my personal example, I'm
not talking about your article >> just to finish that analogy.
>> Well, yeah, but you're trying to draw an analogy. I
just I disagree with the analogy, but sure. Yeah, I'll get that.
>> Okay. Well, again, you're asking a question that I've
already answered because I think if you write an article in which
the bulk of the article talks about the negative experiences
that trans sorry that sis people have experienced, especially
dransitioners who went through the process, anyone who walks
away
like what if all of the trans people through happen stance that
Jesse interviewed were black. Would the implication be that he's
trying to push the narrative that black people are the only people
who transition, right? Like
I just don't know where we're I don't know where we're going
with this. >> From reading that article where the vast
majority of the words are spent interviewing people who had negative
experiences are going to think that the overwhelming amount of
trans people who undergo
transitioning experience.
>> Majority of the article is spent on interviewing it.
Right. There's only two people that you've interviewed in the
article. Again, Scott Padberg, Orian Floss, who by the way both
happen to be he him. I'm also curious as to why every single
person who's a dransitioner
uh was a woman. Was there was that just the people who had been
responding or was that a personal choice? >> You're asking
Sorry, you're asking whether dransitioners or the happily transitioned
are
biological females. >> Yeah. So the dransitioners aka people
who are cis and always were cis are all women. Every single one
of them. And then the people who you I could say are closest
to happily transitioned trans people are both men are both he
him. Was was that an uh editorial decision or is that just >> Oh,
in other words, so everyone involved was a natal female.
>> That's not my question. My question is again, so the
majority of people that you chose, >> you're saying there
were two there were two happily transitioned people and they
were both uh trans guys. >> Yeah, they were both men. >> Of
the two, they were >> Is this like a trick? Is this a trick
question?
I don't even know what Lance is trying to imply here.
no. I mean, there was no No, I mean, that's just like who the
best stories were. There's also, if you go to a youth gender
clinic today, 70 to 80% of the people uh at that clinic for youth
services will be natal females. So, it makes sense that's who
you would find if you look for some kids to talk to. >> So,
it wasn't a decision on your part. It was simply how this worked
out, >> how it shook out. Yeah. Yeah. >> Okay. Understanding.
Did you get to pick the photos that were used out of curiosity?
The pictures. Did you have any editorializing on that? >> Does
the author of an Sorry, you're asking if the author of a Atlantic
piece gets to choose the photos. No, >> no, I'm just asking
if you had any any editorial decision-making. I'm just I'm just
ask I just >> Yeah, that's he just specified. Why? Ah,
there's nothing more frustrating when you're like talking to
somebody and you like try to reiterate their point back to them
to show that you understand and they they go, "No, that's not
what I said." And they repeat the exact same like to you it's
like the exact same thing, right? That's so frustrating.
>> This is not my line of work, right? So, I'm having to
ask you, but I'm curious. >> So, what happened what happened
here unfortunately was a trans model sign.
I'm not going to reiterate the um very >> editors permission
to use their I believe they use they them pronouns at the time
and still do to use their image on the cover. >> Then after
the article came out and they were unhappy about it. Um they
said that they had been lied to somehow which I've never quite
understood cuz to me if I sign a release saying you can use my
photo in this uh but if there's more to that story you can let
me know. But that a lot of people were complaining about that.
I feel like that was unfair to the art department who just like
followed the rules completely and got a release from the model,
but I don't know. I don't have anything to do with that. >> You
said a point redeem where you scream out Canada. Canada.
>> Hold on. Do I still have that on my soundboard? I should.
Where is it?
>> Let's go. >> That decision cuz I'm a freelancer
and a >> Uh I probably could. >> You're not a photographer,
>> right? Absolutely. But so just to be clear, it's he
him. so uses he him pronouns and he was featured on the cover
of the article. Um, do you not think it was unfair to him that,
you know, the way that the article used his photo and then said,
"Your child says she's trans, she wants hormones and surgery,
she's 13." Um, that effectively not only misgendered him, but
then outed him as being trans to his family through the process.
something that's extremely >> Wait, did the person who's
interviewed and took this picture and sent it to them not know
that? That did they not have any say? I would imagine they probably
had a say. >> Dangerous for anyone who's LGBTQ plus. >> I
feel like The Atlantic would absolutely have taken that into
account, right? Like that that would be a horrible look if the
person came out and said, "Oh, you're mis you're misgendering
me on the cover." I'm almost positive The Atlantic would have
taken that into account.
>> They weren't interviewed. They were a model for the
cover. Yeah. Do you think do do we think that the person didn't
know what they were going for? Or I feel like that would just
be a pure nightmare, right? You set this person up, you ask for
a trans person or something, they take a photo and you go, "Well,
actually, you you just secretly misgender them." It's not even
really misgendering because they are. It's like the story you're
telling, right? It's a woman. It's a it's a little girl who's
saying, "I'm trans. I need to transition to male." That is actually
that person's story. Do you think that if a trans person is in
the closet and doesn't want to be outed, they should participate
in a photo about trans people? >> That wasn't my question,
though. You're answering a question with a question. >> That
wasn't my question. You're answering a question with a question.
Yeah, I'm pointing out how you are. That did happen and they
did complain. Okay, but wait, but Jesse just asked the right
question. like uh they can totally complain after >> the
article used his photo and then it was unfair to him that and
he was featured on the cover of the article >> and got
a release from the model but I don't know I don't have >> discusses
being misgendered
for a widely malign 2018 yet he says it pretty much outed me
wait it doesn't say that they're being that they're upset over
being misgendered it says they discuss being misgendered
but Jesse says it
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry. No, no, no. I said, "Do you think
The Atlantic wouldn't discuss this with them? Wouldn't tell them
what the article was about, right? Wouldn't tell them what the
idea was." And Jesse says right there, "No, obviously he like
they told the person what the article was about. >> Have
anything to do with that?" >> We just We could just look
this up. Trans cover model discusses being misgendered.
Trans cover model discusses being
misgendered. Sorry, I was like, there's no way they complained
about this when obviously they would have been obviously they
would have been talked to about this. Okay. In an interview with
trans journalist Sydney Bower for Pointer, Mina Brower, Mina
Brewer, who appeared on the cover of The Atlantic for a widely
maligned 2018 story about trans youth, says he was misgendered
and outed by the magazine's choice of cover line. Brewer's photo
appeared on the cover story uh on the cover to illustrated story
by Jesse Singal, a journalist who has covered the trans community
in notedly dishonest terms in the past. Not true, by the way.
He's been basically vindicated on every single thing he's ever
said. Um, it's unfortunate that like a lot of people will paint
him as just obsessed with trans people. I feel like he was obsessed
with something that he saw as like broadly dangerous and insane
and he's just been maligned for it. But I think he's been essentially
vindicated on all points. He's like, yeah, he's just basically
been vindicated entirely. We'll see. We'll see exactly what was
said. The cover line that Brewer's photo appeared next to was,
"Your child says she's trans. She wants hormones and surgery.
She's 13. Brewer told Pointer that he used the they them pronouns
at the time. He now uses he him pronouns. Was 22 years old and
outed his gender identity to immediate family members before
he felt ready to tell them. Oh, and the article, I guess the
article outed him. Brewer didn't know much about the story how
much didn't know much about the story his photo would be used
to illustrate. He had originally responded to an open casting
call by photographer Mek Jasik who is who has worked for the
New York Times, GQ and the New Yorker among other publications
for a photo on an article about gender dysphoria that debated
different views on teens waiting wanting to transition. According
to Pointer
>> Bob, thank you for the five gifted. Let's go. Thank
you. Thank you. Jique continued by alleging
Jique continued by alleging that the photo would be used as a
general abstract artistic representation of gender dysphoria
in children.
My family is pretty supportive. I didn't really face any hard
transphobia or backlash from them. Brewer told the outlet, "It
pretty much outed me and it was such a weird time. I was really
trying to understand my identity for myself and wasn't really
comfortable talking about my gender to all these people who weren't
that close to me." Brewer contacted The Atlantic to express concern
about the headlines used alongside his photo after the story
was published, but was told there was nothing that could be done.
He was paid an additional sum for the cover.
The article itself features widely misinformed and discredited
ideas about gender. No, it doesn't. No, it doesn't. No, it doesn't.
No, it doesn't. This was correct about everything he said. Can
anybody tell me like what he was? I'm sure at some point Lance
will get to a point where Jesse Singal is incorrect, right? I'm
sure at some point we'll get there where Jesse Singal is wrong.
I would love to see where he's wrong.
Hopefully we'll get there at some point. The article itself,
uh, trans writers such as Heron Walker have referred to the piece
as a smokeokc screen for Singal's anti-trans sentiments. By writing
about trans kids instead of trans adults, he expressed his concern
over the way we live our lives by framing his concern as a parental
one, thus looping parents into the conversation, Walker wrote
for Jezebel. It's a children's issue, not a trans issue, which
gives any reader, Sister Trans, permission to weigh in on the
subject with authority. It's that classic think of the children
straw man. Except the think of the children thing in the in the
thing they're trying to evoke that's saying hey there's a gay
man over there. Think of the children. Don't let them around
the gay man. But that's not what's happening here, right? It's
think of the children. The children are seeking medical care
that they may not be that they may not be able to actually consent
to. They may not might not be able to consent from an informed
perspective. And parents really should be able to say, "Oh no,
hold on. Hold on." There's a ton of criticism online of the article.
I don't think Lance is going to present the best of it. He might
present the best of it, but my my issue is I think I think Jesse
Singal is broadly being totally and entirely vindicated on his
views. And I don't think there's any reason to believe that he
is critical of trans adults. I know that there's a bunch of criticism
for it. I've never seen a single person who's tried to formulate
criticism of it directly to Jesse not look like a [__]
Sam Cedar, M of England,
morons. Lance from the surfs, I'm guessing, but not 100% sure.
So far, but maybe not for the rest of it. [__] I
am very surprised that this person answered a casting call for
for a trans basically to Hey, we're looking for somebody who's
trans for this story about trans like gender transition. What
did you What did you think this was? This is absolutely within
the bounds of what you'd expect. What are we I don't Okay. Okay.
All >> decision cuz I'm
>> I'm a freelancer. I'm a writer, not a >> Right.
Absolutely. But so just to be clear, it's he him. So it uses
he him pronouns and he was featured on the cover of the article
>> but was not he him at the time. >> Um do you not
think it was unfair to him that you know the way that the article
used his photo and then said your child says she's trans, she
wants hormones and surgery. She's 13. um that effectively not
only misgendered him but then outed him as being trans to his
family through the process. Something that's extremely dangerous
for anyone who's LGBTQ plus. >> Do you think I'm sorry
I think that could be a concern. I don't know why they would
do a cover for The Atlantic if they were worried about being
outed as trans for a trans person. Why do you think they wanted
a picture of a trans person to put on the cover of an incredibly
popular and and widely disseminated magazine? Hello. What what
did they think was going to happen? Maybe the misgendering is
bad. I don't think the misgendering is that bad because obviously
they were told that it was going to be for a an article on child
like healthcare. That that phrase if or child trans healthcare,
child gender healthcare, youth gender healthcare is what they
say. That is an entirely possible tagline
for an article on youth gender healthcare. It just is.
think that if a trans person is in the closet and doesn't want
to be outed, they should participate in a photo about trans people.
>> That wasn't my question, though. You're answering your
question with a question. I'm just telling you the reality of
what happened as a result of being in that person against their
will.
>> This is like Okay, this is a result of being in that
photo. >> It's like, do you think it's appropriate that
Mau called Parapon
the hard?
And it's like, well, do you think it was appropriate for Parapon
to engage in a race play dynamic with her partner in which she
was okay and and constantly
uh you know, I actually don't know the exact dynamics, but let's
say arguably she asked for that to happen. Okay, let's say, but
I don't know. I don't know. I haven't seen that, but arguably
she asked for that to happen. And then somebody goes, "Wait,
you're asking a question with a question. Do you think it's appropriate
for her to be called the hard?" It's like well the answer to
that with no other context is no but I'm providing the other
context with my question
which is important important context which is required to make
the decision. So this person against their >> according
to his testimony. Yes. >> Are you saying that she was asking
for it? I'm saying hypothetically in a world where she was asking
for it. Was it appropriate? My belief is that consenting adults
in a private DM chain
can hard r as they so choose. I suppose I know me and Quimman
do, but >> I guess I'm okay. So, like >> people people
use hard R&D sometimes. It's offputting.
It's It's really offputting. I'm just saying. >> I look
I look stereotypically I have a big nose. You don't have to respond
to that, but it's >> Germanium. We've been vindicated.
Jesse has vindicated us. Let's go.
>> True. If I
felt like I didn't want people to know I was
>> and I signed my name to a form saying this is going
to be, you know, a photo gallery of people >> and then
I complained this outed me as that would that would seem pretty
silly to me cuz I signed a like a piece of paper saying I'm giving
you permission to use me for this story about being. So I guess
that's always confused me. I think maybe what this person should
have done if they didn't want to be gouted or weren't out is
not participate in a photo about trans youth, but I can't speak
to their experience or his now. I swear to God if Lance goes
but do you think it was appropriate for them to be misgendered
or something? Do you think it was appropriate for them to be
like outed against their way? If he just asked the same question
like he's literally Marco Rubio, I
am going to enjoy the rest of this >> experience. I'm sorry.
Um, so it's kind of a ground and find out scenario
>> around in the sense of signing a thing saying I'm I'm
being photographed for a story about trans youth.
>> Is that even by around? >> Well, can I just ask
you though? If you do you do you get what I'm saying that like
if you sign something saying
I'm choosing to be featured in this magazine. I mean, what do
you think should have happened? I I think that there's a large
amount of people who are trying to get into a very difficult
field such as modeling or uh anything related to that. And so
if you sign up for something where it's like hey by the way this
is a casting call we're going to be talking to different teens
their views on transition and that's essentially what the casting
call was according to the article that was written about this.
uh and in relation to that they were not aware you know when
this was taking place that you know he was going to be used in
this respect uh to be an article that is now considered to be
highly controversial uh and then the result was signed a release
>> wait wait wait wait wait wait why would the fact that
the article became highly controversial actually matter all that
matters is what they were told at the time and whether or not
that accurately reflected what the article ended up being right
if if as Jesse says it was about um youth gender medicine and
the debate around it that I believe that for the for the article
and the title both things are acceptable that this person was
not misinformed. >> Oh, absolutely. I'm not saying that
this is illegal. That that would be a different accusation, right?
I'm I'm saying yeah, you sign a release. I mean, at the end of
the day, the Atlantic had the legal rights to do with whatever
they wanted with it. Right. When when I >> and morally,
you have no claim. If you sign a release and you're a legal adult
saying you can use my photo for this, you have no moral claim
if someone then uses your photo for it. >> Right. But you
don't think that it's at all unfortunate then? Maybe that's a
way of putting it that as a result. >> I guess I'm curious
how this this person was was outed by being on the cover. Do
you have the backstory on that? >> Yeah. So according to
the article that's in they uh sorry them us. Uh Brewers photo
appeared on the cover to illustrate a story by Jesse Singal,
a journalist who's covered the trans community in notably dishonest
terms in the past. The cover line in Brewer's photo appeared
next to your child says she's trans, she wants hormones and surgeries.
She's 13. Brewer told >> Lance is your countryman. Yeah,
I know. I know. >> Uh told pointer that he used they them
pronouns at the time, but now he uses he him pronouns. That was
22 years ago. And it outed his gender identity to his immediate
family and members before he felt ready to tell them. He didn't
know much about the story that his photo would be used to illustrate.
>> The hypothetical cuts through this entirely. By the
way, >> he had originally responded to an open casting
call by photographer uh so and so who was working for the New
Yorker and the New York Times for a photo on an article about
gender dysphoria that was debating different views on teens wanting
to transition. >> So he so sorry I'm sorry. Current pronouns
is he or they he. Right. >> He him. Yeah.
>> Okay. So he signed a form saying I'm participating in
a photoshop about a photo about teens seeking to transition.
>> Okay. We might have to disagree uh agree to disagree
on this one because to me if I sign a form saying I'm partic
I'm using my why if their parents saw that
that they were basically on a cover for somebody who is trans.
Do they think their parents might go wait are you trans? Wait
are you trans? That seems participating in about this sensitive
issue. It just doesn't make sense to then say I was outed against
my will and I think that's really unfair to sort of the art folks
at the Atlantic who uh that's a really tough story to illustrate.
I have no idea how I would have done it, but I don't think they
did anything wrong. But >> they took a photo of him. They
used the photo for the cover of the Atlantic. And then in that
picture right beside it, it says she wants hormones and surgery.
She's 13. She was 22 at the time. Sorry, he was 22 at the time
in this case. So he was 22 years old. But this >> hold
on. Lance is going to read the part about the pronouns being
different, right? that the they they were possibly like non-binary,
not even like actually fully transition or even on hormones.
>> Front page now says she's 13, she wants hormones surgery
right beside his photo, right? Which again >> I I don't
I'm not trying to use her. I'm going to get pronounced wrong.
It's >> You don't think that is all irresponsible to put
that in giant words right beside his picture. >> But are
they also in the article or just the photo? Just the photo. The
photos. Yes, just the photos. It's just I I feel like we're there's
a crosswires here because like so if there's a photo of about
youth soccer in Time magazine and they get a bunch of kids and
put them in a soccer uniform. Those that no one looking at that
is like that's a real kid who actually plays soccer. It's you're
modeling like you can use a models image in a lot of >> Jesse
saying the top Bronson article right now like if my parents asked
me I just say no I'm just a model. They just wanted a model who
like dressed androgynously and so I filled the role. >> Your
complaint is that it was inaccurate about their gender identity.
>> Yeah absolutely. I mean, well, first off, I I think
like anyone looking at this cover again, especially if you're
not familiar with this topic and you see his face and then you
see the words, uh, you know, misgendering him and, you know,
saying that he's 13 years old, this implication is is probably
for some part of the story. One of the other people that you
interviewed because this person, he's not even featured in your
article, right? Um, but in so >> the funny thing is is
I think they could have used he him pronouns. Your son comes
to you and says they want to transition and the article still
works. The photos still work. Your son says he's trans. He wants
hormones and surgery. He's 13. The article still works. This
person's incredibly androgynous.
I'm It actually works both ways. They just they flip the coin
incorrectly.
Unlucky.
>> So doing that. That's part of the the aspect that I
think is also disingenuous. And >> often times the magazine
cover will like speak in sort of like that's the kind of scenario
the story is about. What do you do if your kid wants to go on
hormones or get surgery, >> right? And again, this is something
that you have nothing to do with. You didn't pick the the words
that would appear on the cover of the Atlantic. that was their
own editorial decision, but it's just something that you also
don't feel morally conflicted about because >> you agreed
to it. >> I feel off because it's fine if if if this person
was unhappy with their decision to participate in the photo,
that's fine. I just I felt like the Atlantic got a little bit
of a raw deal because they didn't do anything wrong. And I still
haven't heard from you what they did wrong. Uh well, I I think
the first thing that they did wrong was uh put in giant bold
letters uh that you know he is a 13-year-old uh he is a she and
that again anyone who's seen this cover for >> he's not
even quoting the cover correctly cuz he's so scared of misgendering.
This is very funny. >> Well, if you were the family members
of like his family obviously I suppose according to him saw this
cover recognize him and then was like >> we're going to
speed through this part of the debate once they get off the actually
where's the criticism of Jesse? The best you could do here is
a criticism of the photographer andor the Atlantic. These are
not Jesse's points. Jesse apparently didn't have maybe he didn't
make this clear, but like he probably doesn't control the cover
of The Atlantic, right? I don't see how he possibly could. >> Well,
you know, at the time he was going by them, but now, you know,
based on this cover, uh, you know, did this your 13-year-old
want hormones and surgery. Uh, and it turns out that he in fact
was trans and has undergone, you know, gender firing care. But
that was true. So that is just that he shouldn't have. >> Maybe
what information was was not privy to Joe. uh the fact that he
was trans, >> but he signed a release to be in I don't
I'm sorry. Like he signed a release saying I'm going to be in
a photo shoot about trans kids, right? >> That's that's
on you, right? Like you give me that decision. It's
>> So Lance, what Lance doesn't understand is he's already
forfeited this point. He lost this point completely. You've lost
entirely on the out it to your parents thing. They signed a they
signed a release. That point is over. We're done with that, Lance.
Move on to the other one, which is like, well, do you think it's
okay that they're misgendered? Now their their pronouns were
they them. And for the sake of the story and for the sake of
the the um like saying like the call to the past and like actually
explaining the difficult hypothetical,
they should be using she. That makes the most sense, right? It's
not current pronouns. So like I think editorially I don't think
they did something wrong. Maybe you could argue this person feels
bad about it now and maybe it's like that's unfortunate, but
that's the best you could do is that's unfortunate.
>> Releases. The reason to sign a photo release is to say
I'm letting my photo out into the world. Uh, I think I I got
the sense he wasn't happy with the article. She has every right
to be, but >> no, I guess if you want to ask for an extreme
comparison, if there was a photo say me, they used my photo and
it was in an interview where I was discussing say how much I
hate white supremacists or white supremacist and they use my
picture on the cover and then all of a sudden there's a quote
beside it and it was like the leading white supremacists in Canada,
but my picture was right there. And I'm in the article speaking
out against that. I would say that was a disingenuous way of
using my photo even though I signed a release form, even though
I agreed to be part of this photo. They they were manipulating
the way my picture is now being perceived by the public. I think
>> but hold on. It would be hold on. It would be cuz I
don't think there's anything from this this cover tagline, right?
This is absolutely in line with what they said for the release.
You're going to be use your photo is going to be released. If
if they said um because it is about transitioning, childhood
transition, that's what this is about. If they told Lance like
it's going to be about combating white supremacy
by any means necessary, and he signed a release, then I'd say
he probably has no leg to stand on, right? Yeah. White
Yeah, that's probably like what you signed a release for. the
release is accurate. That's the issue. I think your argument
would be >> despite what hypothetical despite whatever
hypotheticals he comes up with, he's not he's not getting out
of the fact that the release is accurate. >> You're right.
If they had listed the model's name and if it wasn't like such
an abstracted photo illustration in your example, they're using
you Lance like an actual like um but I will say like we should
we should talk more about stuff I've actually written. But I'm
happy to defend on this week. >> I can move on then. So
I wanted to talk about the uh the newer studies that have come
up because you said you you've not heard of any studies that
actually show that you know the rates of uh you know children
who actually desist are low. Um this is something I >> sorry
des every time desistence or >> Well we can we can talk
about both. Uh we can talk about satisfaction rates for children
who uh you know transition and >> desistence would be
um starting a transition and then stopping
right and drans would be completing a transition and then retransitioning
back to the original gender. Right? at which point uh you know
how they feel and how much satisfaction they have and how many
of them actually choose to dransition. >> But this is something
at which the overwhelming amount of data that has come out internationally
from study after study on this topic shows very very very low
rates of dransitioning to the point where for someone to infer
that they could be high or low like >> this is again not
my area of expertise. This is something you've written way more
about than I have. But you know, have you pulled up the levels
of satisfaction and regret after gender affirming care in adolescence
2024 US study uh which showed 97% continued access to gender
affirming care and their satisfaction rate was 6.5 out of seven
on an average of six to 10 years after transition. >> Sure.
So the problem here is there's also a study based on like US
military healthcare records where um I forget I don't I forget
the exact number. I'll include a link to all these studies in
our show notes. Uh 25% had discontinued a few years later. And
Kinnan McKinnon's point, this is this researcher who studies
this stuff, is that depending on how you ask the question, you
get a lot of different answers. And a lot of the studies saying
a one or two or 3% regret rate only count kids who come back
to the clinic and say, "I transitioned, here I am." Uh, and that's
if a lot of them don't come back because they feel like they
were burned by uh clinics that didn't give them good care. So
I used to say
uh I cited this uh statistic that >> so basically there
are studies that'll say 2 to 3% drans or desistence rate but
the idea is they don't actually check up with people who drop
off. They only check up with people who come in and talk to them.
If you've had a bad experience, you don't think you receive good
care. Maybe you desist fairly early and you you just don't think
it was for you. You you go back you you sorry. You uh go back
on your decision. You never really go back to the clinic. You
just go, "Oh, that was weird. Bye." you never think about it
again. Which when you think like realistically that makes a lot
of sense that a lot of people just drop off. You need to have
like actual forced follow-ups, not force like Yeah, forced follow-ups.
Yeah, you need to actually go and chase them down and say like,
"Hey, just need to check in and see what happened here." The
desistance rate, not dransition, desistance is 80%. I no longer
use that because I think there's a lot of fuzziness here. I just
feel the same way about the dransition research. I think we have
there's an article I'll I'll include a link to and this is just
one person's opinion. It is a peer-reviewed article. Uh the dransition
rate is unknown. The author is con archives of behavior. That's
my view is the dransition rate is unknown because if I have a
100 patients who come through my clinic and uh two years later
I reach out to them and I get in touch with 50 of them and they're
all happy. Um that's not a 0% dransition rate. It's an I don't
know dransition rate cuz I've lost track of 50 of them or 50%
of them. Do you get what I'm saying? Like if you don't know what
>> I get what you're saying, but you immedately just took
a peer-reviewed study that I was referencing and this is a a
recent one. this one was from 2024 and discounted it just out
out of the gates and said yeah >> well he's he's explaining
why he's discounting it so you can engage with the argument or
>> the truth is that hey by the way there's another study
that shows you know if we interview military personnel that this
is just not the case but that's one of again many studies you
can pull up there's reidentification with register Australian
pediatric clinic this was an Australian study of 552 patients
they showed 1% of trans youth reidentified with their sex at
birth 4% >> okay I I have this turned up slightly 1.25
I can Western Australian pediatric gender clinic. This was an
Australian study of 552 patients. They showed 1% of trans youth
reidentified with their birth. 4% said reidentified during mental
health assessments period or earlier did not proceed with gender
affirming care. >> Reidentified as their birth gender.
>> There's also a more nuance story. The pediatric gender
affirming healthcare is associated with satisfaction confidence
from 2024. This one once again 88% expressed satisfaction. 86.7%
felt confident out of 141 on hormones. Only one person zero.
Sorry. Sorry. So Jesse's argument here, Lance is just trying
to hammer through a bunch of studies that people have engaged
with that Jesse's tried to engage with and say, "Hey, uh, if
people drop off of the study and you don't actually follow up
with them, you aren't like you aren't like tangibly following
up with them." That's you don't know what happened to them. You
can't say, "Well, they dropped off, so I'm actually going to
mark that they um I'm not going to count them in any way." That's
like really bad. And Jesse's now trying to ask Lance, "Hey, uh,
what's the drop off rate on these studies that you're referencing?"
And Lance is just continuing to read off numbers as if he he's
just not even remotely engaging, right? He just his talking points
he wants to go through and spam as much as he can. And he is
totally ignoring what Jesse is saying. It just I would like,
you know, obviously I would like critical engagement from Lance.
Um, I have a better chance of getting on top of my apartment
building and jumping off and being able to fly, discovering spontaneous
human flight. Okay. want to finish saying this because I need
I think it's important for your audience. Only one person, 0.7%
regretted both hormone therapy and surgery. Now, for longitudinal
studies, which is something that I know you've often asked about
as well, there's the gender identity 5 years after social transition.
This one was 2022 in the US, which included 317 youth, 28 trans
girls, 109 trans boys, and I think this is one of the ones that
you personally critiqued, but 94% maintained their gender identity
without regret. Sorry, without regret. 3 >> without regret.
Without regret, we got smango daggle on the call. I became non-binary
and only 2.5 reverted back to being cis. And of all these studies,
the reason that is often given for people who do dransition uh
or even in desistance cases is social stigma. The social stigma
that's applied to this. Now, I think one of the the problems
you have when people want to go back and forth on the data and
even if it's someone like me who wants to, you know, exclusively
refer to peer-reviewed studies only is that you can look at meta
analysis of the studies. You you can look at, you know, pooling
of the studies, right? Like there's the regret after gender affirmations
study. Uh the systematic review that one analyzes 27 >> You
mean the one in the journal of sorry it analyzed how many? >> Uh
this one analyzes 27 studies pulling 7,928 trans patients internationally.
And of that study the majority of them are on are on adults.
>> I feel bad but I'm not like they're talking over me.
Let me just cuz I'm I'm very familiar with these studies. So
the one you just mentioned they doubled their sample size through
an error. Their sample size was 50% high. Let me pull up the
actual This is Bootos at all. Right. >> Uh hold on. >> Yeah.
Regret after gender affirmation surgery. A systematic review
of meta analysis of uh prevalence. >> Yes, it's bootos.
>> Um this was a study I've written about it. They I forget
the exact it was they basically doubled their sample size because
they did not correctly transfer the data from the studies they
were looking at into their meta analysis. And to this day, there's
this team, I think it's one psychiatrist in Australia and a few
re >> It's just very funny when you have like a a lightly
research or a a
poor diversity of research in a specific topic and people can
become familiar with all of the papers and then there's somebody
who's like clearly just trying to, you know, get their points
through no matter what. And the other person could easily be
be familiar with all of the papers as Jesse obviously would be
cuz this is like his one topic of total like knowledge. I feel
like I've actually seen this happen directly with Jesse Singal
in other conversations where people will try to site a paper
badly and he will explicitly point out why the study is bad for
the point they're trying to make. And I've seen it happen multiple
times. So I just don't understand why people keep doing it. It
just keeps happening again and again and again.
Researchers uh in London or thereabouts who've been trying to
get them to correct the numerous errors with it. Now, even if
I've written about this um study in particular, even if you accepted
their claims at face value, the overall loss to follow-up rate
was 40%. So, there's two things here. If this was a great meta
analysis, we would still not know what happened to 40% of the
participants, but they they just won't correct their errors.
There's sort of a long paper trail. And unfortunately, I found
this like before I got into the gender stuff, I wrote a whole
book about other sort of popular science ideas where there was
very little accountability and researchers don't correct their
errors. And it's just science is in a bad place right now. It
isn't just youth gender medicine. But I would just make two points.
One of which is this is the single most viral study on the regret
question. Uh despite having all sorts of uncorrected errors and
if the overall loss to follow-up rate is 40% that means you don't
know. So the Australian study you just mentioned you probably
don't I don't think you what's the loss to follow-up rate do
you know that
>> uh is this the one in which so there's >> the
Australian clinic >> yeah so in that case when you're saying
there's a loss of 40% of the people who return to ask the questions
right that doesn't mean that you can classify them as desisters
or dransitioners or >> that's not what he's trying to do
idiots just not even listening he's not even listening
he's saying you don't know so obviously re making major recommendations
when you actually don't know when there's half of the Dude, could
you imagine if you were doing a like medication trial, okay,
and 50% of the participants dropped out and then you went, "Hey,
despite the fact that we like actually formed this cohort for
this trial, trying to, you know, create a like widespread population
or a wide representation of the population, despite the fact
that we're like trying to do all these things to make sure we
have all of our bases covered, 50% of people dropped out, but
we're still going to approve the medication." That would be insane.
That would be I feel like if that happened the FDA would go no
no you have to restart your trial immediately right. Yes. He
said it unknown exactly like it's it would immediately like cause
this drug to be thrown like they'd have to redo their trials
immediately. Like you just you you can't have 50% of your data
be gone and then you're like well and then and then by the way
what they'll do is it's like it's explicit confirmation bias.
Hey all of the people who have had good outcomes from our care
will keep coming back to the clinic. We'll check back in. they
won't they won't drop off, right? And then I'm going to present
the data at the end as if that's like oh the true rates guys
like 1% 2% drans boom we solved it. The the what do you call
it like the motivated reasoning required to do that is so obvious
and it's really gross that people defend it. Although I won't
pretend people defend it a lot. In fact, at this point, could
you not easily easily easily
argue that Lance like Lance is like a PV? Like a How did Lance
not get in PV is like what I'm trying to say cuz he could easily
be getting paid by Peter Teal. Like that is maybe the most likely
outcome right now. Lance is just getting paid by Peter Teal under
the table and nobody nobody knows. Actually, Lance is like 160
IQ. Gigachad who gets all the time. He gets laid all the time.
This guy constantly 160 IQ chess tres h ch ch ch ch ch ch ch
grandmaster in Canada. All right, no downsides in his life. He
is just nothing but net and everything and he just collects,
you know, $100,000 monthly from Peter Teal to go out and keep
making these stupid points about trans people so that somebody
on YouTube can hold him up and go, "Look how crazy lefties are."
Jesus had a hard time getting through that. >> No, no,
what I'm saying is if you Right. >> God, like I just look
at him as like he's not participating in the conversation. He
just wants to make some points that everyone knows and probably
set back like progressive boob significantly when somebody's
arguing these things online.
Speaking of as a part of this, I also got linked a uh a highlight
a highlight reel. Okay, a highlight reel
from his debate with Tim P. Hold on there a minute. Tim P exposes
hypocrisy of proabortion guest in mic drop moment. >> If
you're the person that is alive outside of a womb, then that's
murder, >> Yeah, I'd agree. Can I ask you this is not a
gotcha. That's great. I want to ask in good faith. So >> yeah,
of course. >> You believe that the moment after the child
is outside of the birth canal >> that they are now endowed
with human rights. Yes. >> However, when they are inside
of the mother, literally anything you do to them is acceptable
because they're inside of the mother. >> Oh, no. I don't
think anything is acceptable. But I think the mother should still
have the choice ultimate uh authority over what happens to her
body. >> But there's a child. >> Oh god. We actually
need Dean Wither's opinion on this suddenly. Can I get Dean's
opinion on this? Dean Withers. Dean Withers. Hello. Dean Wii.
I need Dean Wither's opinion on this. Okay. The parent has ultimate
authority. He's got to soy the out about heard. >> What
about meth? >> He's Oh, >> I clicked off of the birth
canal that they are not mother. Literally, anything you do to
them is acceptable because they're inside of the mother. >> Oh,
no. I don't think anything is acceptable, but I think the mother
should still have the choice ultimate uh authority over what
happens to her body. >> But there's a child inside of her
body. Hold on. Wait, isn't there another body there?
What? >> What about meth?
>> Uh, [__] >> Like, should you be allowed
to do meth?
>> Uh, I think if someone is doing meth while they're pregnant
that it is. >> So, this is like a shot obviously because
if you say yes to meth, then it's like, okay,
you say yes to meth, it's like, okay, you're defending any action
then cuz that is an action that has no upside to the bomb, right?
All only downside to the child. If you say no, then well, she
doesn't have ultimate authority. Obviously, there's some reason
she shouldn't do that. You've you've basically seated the argument
as well. There's just like there's no way to answer this question
and look good. And if I recall correctly, he bites all of the
bullets to take like mother's mother's right to choose is over
everything, right? She decided that she she really just wanted
to taste human flesh and decided that she was going to have a
back alley abortion where they cut the kid out of her and cut
it up. Okay. Well, hold on. They have to kill the kid while it's
inside. But then they cut it out of her and then they roasted
it and ate it. Lance would have to go, "Yeah, that's totally
awesome." >> Is completely acceptable for something like
uh
I don't know what the name of the services in the United States.
>> Child services
would be her body though. >> Yeah, it's her body. >> She
wants to do meth. What's the big
>> Uh the big deal is that it's she's intentionally trying
to kill the child. >> Can you? >> Dude, I forgot
the way he answered it. The way he answers it is so bad.
Why? Why did he answer it that way? Like literally, you could
say, "Well, you could answer that so many ways." And he answered
it in the exact way that makes him look the most. Okay, that's
that's where you have to go. Okay, this guy's getting paid by
Peter Teal. This guy's like 150 IQ, graduated from some insane
arts college, actual trained theater actor, is just pretending
to be and collecting his paycheck. Okay, that has to be it. That
has to be it. >> You say that again. >> She's intentionally
trying to kill the >> Let's go. Wait, why is it a child?
>> Hold on there a minute. Yeah. And I >> I was like,
dude, there's no way you just said that. Oh, I forgot how awesome
this debate was.
There's no way you just said that. >> Yeah. And I see
>> I don't I don't understand what you're >> It's
her body. She wants to do meth. What's the problem? >> Well,
first off, doing meth is illegal. Period. Doesn't matter if you're
doing it with a child or without a child.
>> Dude,
like that's that's Lance's only purpose on the internet, by the
way, is for right-wingers to like dunk on. He's like the last
he's the last vestage of hope for right-wingers who are like
still in the Ben Shapiro leftwing obliterated era. Okay, they
get him on something and they get to just like dunk on him repeatedly
for how he is. >> Lost a follow. >> Guy is kind of
a treasure to be honest. >> Just means you don't know.
I would I would I I don't know like how many of them dransitioned
or desisted. Uh but the point is if you've lost 40% of your sample
and I don't in the Australian one you brought up as a 2024 one
do you know what the loss of follow-up rate in that one is? >> Uh
no I don't have the data. >> Okay. Um that and so again
this is like uh I've >> you're talking about the 2024 reidentification
with B registered and Western Australian pediatric gender clinic
cohort. >> This is the one you mentioned as an example
how >> yeah the one that you're invoking that I invoked
that would be the one from 2024.
>> well, I would just say it's probably important to know
what the loss to followup rate is. Now, I think the Dutch have
probably done the best job. They have a couple of studies where
people who go through this pretty intensive diagnostic process
where like I think trans activists think it's too harsh, but
it's like if you have a lot of other mental health coorbidities,
they don't let you transition. I think they've done a couple
studies where like loss of follow-up isn't too high and if you
go through this strict process, yeah, the outcomes appear to
be pretty good. But the the you I don't know how things are going
in Canada. In the US, we have a totally different protocol where
a lot of clinics are not doing a lot of gatekeeping. And >> dude,
he must get money, right? He's got 100,000 subs. He must get
money. Although only 7,000 views on this debate. He's got 100,000
subs.
Oh boy. He does not get He does not get great views. They're
okay. I don't know. I don't know if this is enough.
3 weeks ago. I don't know if this is enough for views right here.
I always wonder at this point like do you just start a new YouTube
channel at this point too? Because like if you don't just start
a new YouTube channel once you've like fallen off and you have
100,000 subs I think you just kind of get totally
I think having people in your sub in your sub count in your sub
in your subscriptions and your followers or whatever on any social
media platform having a low percentage of them who actually still
follow you and are like uh big big boosters of you. I think that
just totally everything in like every social media algorithm,
right? Like if they don't want to watch your stuff and like it,
if they get served it and they don't click through, that's actually
the worst thing you can have happen. Like at that point, you
just start a new channel completely. I think anyway, we could
you could you >> and I guess that's what worries me cuz
I don't think there would be much of a story here if like in
every case of a >> start about Nuxor. Nuxinor has always
been his stream channel, I think. >> Give me two seconds.
I mean, blockers. There's been an extensive assessment period.
Um, but we just we know from Reuters reporting, from a little
bit of my reporting, that that's that's not the norm. Um, so
that's what I'm worried about. And that's why I think like it's
important to dig into these regret studies and say if you know
if you have kids coming through your clinic and you're giving
them major medical treatments and then 40 uh% of them disappear
and I'm um 40% it's usually lower than that but you know 30%
and you can't follow up with them. How can how can you say it's
a successful treatment or that they're happy? You don't know
that. So that's why I say the dransition rate in my view is unknown.
I would not say it's super high, which some gender critical activists
do. Uh just cuz like, you know, the dransition subreddit is getting
bigger, that doesn't tell us it's high. I also I I have no confidence
it's low because every time I've looked at a study that seems
to say it's low, it has what to me are pretty major
So speaking about the United States, um again, yeah, I I think
you uh are very
>> good at at pulling apart, you know, small specific parts
about uh you know, individual studies and going the back and
forth. Have you mentioned that conclusively every major medical
association in the United States agrees upon gender forbidden
care, that it's a valid form of health care, and that it should
be
uh acceptable uh for doctors to use? And the same applies to
Canada. every major medical association in Canada strongly supports
gender firming care, including access to puberty blockers and
hormones.
>> Well, I mean, first of all, that's that's not true because
the American Academy of Pediatrics is doing a new systematic
review. Um, >> it's 100%
I'm sorry. the American Academy of Pediatrics, the American Medical
Association, the American Psych Psychiatric Association, the
American Psychological Association, the Endocrine Society, Pediatric.
>> I'm guessing I'm guessing that he's hiding behind the
idea that gender affirming care could be as light as social transition
and that most of these things would say social transition isn't
like a major downside for somebody, right? I'm guessing >> the
Green Society, American Academy of Child Assistance and Psychiatry,
the National Association of Social Workers, and American College
of Obstitricians and Gynecologists,
they all have statements that are still available on their websites.
Now, that could change as you're suggesting right now. The American
Academy of Patriotics could change their stance on that, but
as of right now, every major medical association in the United
States agrees and strongly supports gender firming
>> They don't they don't strongly support it. So, they
all use different language. Some of them will say like in the
case of wellassessed youth or something like that in the case
of the AAP
they put out a 2018 policy statement where this one guy Jason
Rafferty uh he wrote it and usually when you have a statement
he mentioned puberty blockers can be a part of gender affirming
care but if it's just gender affirming care which was his beginning
definition unless he said like including gender or sorry including
puberty blockers and was serious about it I can't see that every
organization would support puberty blockers. I don't think that
could possibly be true >> from at least not up to this
point >> medical group of the whole group right not just
one guy or like a a committee. So this was an unusual case where
one guy wrote it. It says at the bottom this is his responsibility
and his responsibility alone and it's a strange statement that
I think has a lot of inaccuracies. Um now I know that in your
world the cast review has been debunked which I just think is
wrong. I've written about that. the cast review. One of the useful
things it did was look at the existing standards put out by these
groups and it basically just showed that there's not a good scientific
process uh underlying these statements and I think in some cases
there's a case to be made that there's been political pressure
uh in the case of WPATH. We know from documents that fell out
of these court cases that there was political pressure. So I
guess I think you're too trusting of the medical establishment
because like medical these are they're not purely scientific
groups like what some of the the American Medical Association
and groups like it have been against Medicare for all. They've
been in favor of these ridiculous laws that make it hard for
like Indian doctors to come over here and practice. So they have
they have they're not right about everything. Like you're I'm
guessing you are for Medicare for all, right? >> I think
you've changed the topic like three times in one sentence and
you're trying to just deviate away from the fact that every single
association in the United States agrees upon this. You can start
to poke holes in that by saying that their statement isn't as
strong as you feel it is. But that is a just a universal fact
right now as of as of our recording that that every single medical
association major medical association in the United States agrees
upon this. Now if you want to talk about the cast wait if you
want to talk about the cast review we can eventually get to that
because again I want to talk about this in a terms of like I
I'm not an expert on this. I I'm not a scientist, right? So I
I have to actually look this stuff up. But this is universal
as well within Canada. If you're not aware, the Canadian Pediatric
Society, the Canadian Medical Association, the Canadian Psychological
Association, and the Canadian Psychiatric Association all agree
that again they support gender affirming care, including the
use of puberty blockers and hormones for youth. >> This
this totality of the major medical associations that would determine
whether or not this should be safe for children to do. >> So
So let let's stick to the Canadian ones, which you're probably
more familiar with. When you say they support it, do they support
it like an informed consent model or a lengthy assessment? What
exactly are they in favor of? >> So, I wrote down a little
paragraph on each one of their endorsements. So, the Canadian
Pediatric Society recommends gender affirming care, including
puberty blockers and hormone therapy under informed consent models.
The Canadian Medical Association endorses access to gender affirming
care and opposes bans for political interference. The Canadian
Psychological Association supports affirming care and mental
health support for trans youth. And the Canadian Psychiatric
Association affirms that gender affirming care is evidence-based
and medically appropriate. So the sorry the first one you mentioned
is that informed consent for young people or >> maybe it's
just me but there's something so distracting about Lance's hairline
I can't tell where his sideburns end and his temples begin. Usually
you get like a little hook here but yeah I don't know I just
so weird to me >> I wasn't focused on it but thank you
for bringing it up for everybody else >> both feels like
there should be a little
clinic and wants hormones they should just get hormones. >> No,
not at all. >> If they sign the
sign you you've spoken about the DSM5 before, right? and you're
aware of how the system itself works. >> No, informed consent,
the whole point of informed consent is there's not gatekeeping.
That's what in informed consent is if you're told the risks and
benefits of this treatment, you can consent to it. You can fill
out a form, >> right? But in the case of you saying that
like you could just walk into a door and walk out with puberty
blockers, that's not how someone would be diagnosed with gender
dysphoria.
>> But under the informed consent model, it doesn't matter
what their diagnosis is. The point is informed consent >> absolutely
it does. Sorry,
how do you think the DSM5 works? Do do you think that people
simply walk into the like the clinic and and they say, "I I like
girls, but I want to dress up like a boy." And then they're like,
"Okay, here's hormones." >> You sorry. Do you do you know
what informed consent means? >> But now now you're backtracking.
I again >> just thought that's awesome. So what happened
there for everybody who's like paying attention is Jesse is realizing
that Lance doesn't quite have the like um lexicon to have this
conversation and he's basically backs up to like you know what
um you know what important consent is? Now you're backtracking.
No, no, no. I'm trying to I'm trying to help you. I'm trying
to drag you along so we can have an actual conversation. >> Tell
me yes or no. Do you know what informed consent means, >> Jesse?
Specifically, >> dude. Dude, that's also Lance's That's
a huge downside for Lance, too, isn't it? Where Lance like can't
answer a question directly like that cuz he doesn't want to get
he knows he's got. He knows the guy thinks he hasn't got and
so he'll just go Jesse, I'm trying to ask you a question, right?
He's ESL though, right? Is he from Quebec? He doesn't sound ESL.
He sounds like he grew up somewhere where they just speak English
and have a normal like angle accent in Canada. I can't detect
any Quebec there when it comes to how they actually walk into
these clinics that are treated. Neither of us are doctors, right?
>> So, in world, do you know what informed consent means?
Because this is important to the point I'm trying to make. >> I've
we've already defined informed
>> What What does it mean? >> Recommends gender care,
including pub blockers and hormones therapy under the informed
consent models. >> Okay. You're googling informed consent
model. What do you find? >> No, I'm opening up their website
cuz I want to get to it. >> Okay. You don't know, dude.
Just say it's you're not know a lot of >> Sorry. Go ahead.
>> I think you don't know what informed consent means and
that's causing a roadblock in the conversation. Under an informed
consent model for youth, if that's what this group supports a
13-year-old, if they're informed of the costs of the potential
harms and benefits of the treatment, a 13-year-old can go on
hormones right away. That's what informed consent means in the
context of transgender healthcare. >> No, they would be
in favor of that. They could be no >> Jesse. They would
still need to actually be determined. Sorry. Yeah. Doctor would
still need to be determining whether or not that individual actually
in fact has the what five of the seven uh >> noifications.
The whole point of informed consent is it was a response to gatekeeping
because for decades trans adults felt like doctors were poking
and proddding them and asking personal questions. Informed consent
was an alternative to that where your said the doctor says here's
what the hormones will do. Here are the potential downsides.
sign this form and we'll give them to you. So that's why informed
consent clinics are so popular, including at some of our Planned
Parenthoods in the states.
>> But then what what I don't understand what your problem
is with that then. >> Okay.
So
okay. Um how could you sign up for this debate be critiquing
Jesse's article and then say you don't know what his problem
with that is? Obviously, he thinks the entire premise of the
article is that some of these people are not equipped to handle
an informed consent model. Like in the example where the where
the girl was raped as a child and basically she feels like that
that emotional trauma led to her feeling gender dysphoria. She
was like disassociated at least her feeling gender dysphoria
and it wasn't persistent. it wasn't going to persist. And if
somebody had evaluated her and gatekept her, right, she probably
would never have transitioned in the first place. That is the
entire premise of the article. And I I literally don't understand
why you would ask that. That question has to be that question
might be where I'd tap out. I'd be like, I can't I can't I can't
I can't
I hope I hope Jesse answer asks or sorry answers his question
with a question and just says, did you read my article? Do you
know what the thesis of my article is? Because that would be
my answer to your question.
>> But then what what I don't understand what your problem
is without them >> with a 13-year-old be able to walk in
and get hormones. >> But they wouldn't be able to under
>> consent. If underinformed >> this guy has a universal
capability to turn into Patrick Star at any given >> Consent.
That's what informed consent is in the states. We don't we don't
have that for 13-year-olds. Uh you're saying, unless you're misunderstanding
the statement, you're saying like for youth informed consent
would mean that. Yeah. So, I'm going to look this up at their
>> Yeah. Yeah, sure. Also, if you drop a link in the chat,
I could read the exact
>> So, I guess my bigger question would be then if every
single one again cuz you know neither of us are doctors, but
if every major medical association in both organizations agrees
>> I've been trying to I've been trying to answer your
question, dude. You said you said every major medical association
supports it. And my point is >> point is one, no. Two,
depends on what they support. And three, if they support this,
then they're just wrong. Like a lot Lance is asking like how
could you possibly go against medical
and another premise of the article is some of these organizations
seem to have been pressured from a political perspective and
they're not sticking to science at all. They're actually just
totally up. It's another major premise of the article >> is
clearly like you wouldn't follow what a medical association says
blindly and you just said one of the medical
>> this medical association just told me that the treatment
for my sore tooth is to stick a shotgun in my mouth and pull
the trigger. Well, who am I to judge? Okay, the medical organization
said do it, so obviously that's the treatment. I got to Listen,
my tooth hurts. I got to stick a shotgun in my mouth and pull
the trigger. The leader of this all every Canadian medical organization
says this. It's crazy. I wouldn't expect it, but I'm going to
try it. I guess >> informed consent for youth. >> So,
you're you're against what they say. You don't believe in informed
consent for youth on this issue. >> The CBS emphasizes
that very young people develop different race. Decisions should
be based on cognitive >> Oh my god. Hold on. Yes. It's
this exact >> Bear right.
>> No, not there. >> It said right. It said take
a right. >> No, no, no, no, no. Look, it it means go up
to the right. Bear right over the bridge and hook up with 307.
>> Make a right. >> Maybe it's a shortcut, Dwight.
It said go to the right. >> It can't mean that. There's
a lake >> I think it knows where it is going. The machine
knows. >> Stop yelling at me. >> Stop yelling. >> There's
no room here. >> That's actually just exactly what happened.
This is exactly what Lance is suggesting. Or I guess Jess Jesse
here is is Dwight. Okay, it's unlucky. Just the doctors are clearly
wrong. According to Jesse, he's laid out his his argument. You
just argue against his argument. You're just if the only point
here was to say, "Well, doctors disagree with you." He's like,
"Yeah, my my article is calling medical associations out for
being too permissive at this." Yeah, that is the point. >> Not
chronological age. He's consent to gender affirming care, gender
firming approach recognizes interventions that may be social,
psychological, and medical. They say that PB blockers is considered
safe and used when appropriately within a copion of protocsyological
care. Decision-making and medical treatments include puberty
blockers hormone should be private dialogue amongst youth, their
providers and their families. Yeah. So this should be a private
dialogue between youth, their providers and their families according
to their model. Yeah, I'll send you this
point of that is exactly what I agree with whether or not you
can find like yes like I've told you before, this is not my area
of expertise. Uh this is something I believe should be between
again families, doctors. No way. It's not his area of expertise.
We couldn't help. >> They're healthcare provisioners. And
I think what you and me do essentially, you being a journalist,
me being someone who disseminates the news in an entertaining
way for people to watch online, what the two of us are effectively
doing is we are crafting narratives. And then one of the things
that you were doing when you say that >> Okay, this if
I didn't tap out before, if I was debating this guy, this is
where I'd tap out if I were Jesse. You just you just went, "Yeah,
we're kind of just both, right?" No. No. We are not the same.
Compare me again with you and I will crash the out. Okay. We
are not the same. Do not try to compare or say we're doing the
same thing. Shut your >> You are going to be in opposition.
>> Like you work so hard you do a career of like this kind
of journalism calling out like basically where science has gone
wrong where where there's like mistakes in medical research and
then you focus on child youth healthcare or sorry youth gender
medicine. You focus on this specifically and you point out you
do a ton of research. you figure it out and then you have like
this who want to just like yell that the things that you're saying
are wrong without actually listening to what you're saying.
I would lose it >> to the majority of the scientific consensus
on this because the >> which is cleverly why I've never
applied myself to research in that way. Okay, I've never become
that informed that Lance can't get me in the same way he's getting
Jesse right now. Okay, I'm not that informed on any topic. majority
of the scientific consensus seems to agree on these facts is
that ultimately >> well that's but that's also not true
because we haven't even got into like the actual systematic reviews
in places like Sweden, Norway, Finland,
UK like all of Europe has gone in a different direction. Now
I'm not saying we should favor one over I mean this would get
very in the weeds. I'm not trying to get us in the weeds. At
the very least you have to admit that like over in Europe uh
in some pretty good healthare systems they've gotten much more
conservative on these treatments. They have concerns and those
concerns are probably not made up by internet trolls, I would
think. >> No, I I think that they are more politically
motivated than they are scientifically motivated. I think that
there's clearly a a a broad consensus amongst the scientific
community on this topic and that there there are obviously going
to be individual studies for people who try to poke holes in
it using again you know rhetorical tricks uh the tried to you
know find out whether or not you understand the >> Lance
is stuck in like 2020 2019 maybe >> you know this as a
simple definition but like I I agree that like >> well
so you're you're saying that so your view is the American Medical
Association the American Academy of They offer non >> maybe
you could say like 2021 2022 I think by 2022 most people like
oh this is actually we got to we got to chill >> politicized
guidance whereas the government of Finland or the government
of Norway those are too politicized to trust that's the basic
argument >> it's not an argument I don't know enough >> I
don't know how you could have the Norway roll backs yeah you
get the Norway roll backs and you have the cast report and you
go this is just accepted medical silence silence science bigot
Okay, listen bigot. This is trans youth
gender medicine. This is a solved topic. Okay, bigot. Just accept
the science >> about what is going on in Finland specifically?
So, I don't think I'd be able to speak on it. Right. So, I I
mean like Okay, how about how about this? Like you as a person
Yeah. How many articles have you written on gender affirming
hearing trans people do you think in totality? I mean, I've >> by
the way, I couldn't I was basically um I was kind of like I read
Jesse Singal's article and maybe like one or two other articles
he'd written on this topic and then I would occasionally debate
DJs in DG chat about it and they would just get blown the out
like every single time and I'm like and they're like, "Oh, you
know, you haven't done as much research in this topic as I have."
And I'm like, "No, I haven't. I'm literally just I'm just quoting
this guy." I literally would link the article. I'm like, "I'm
just quoting this guy. If you could tell me where this guy, just
argue against this guy because like that's that's literally all
I just read Jesse's stuff and then I was like, I don't need to
be informed, but can you tell me why this is wrong? Never. Nobody
ever can. It's I don't want to sound like I'm like glazing this
guy either. It's just it's goofy to me how this guy I don't know
that there's anybody else online who is like as correct and also
as maligned at the same time. I don't know what causes that,
right? Like this guy is just has just been right like 95% right
for years and years and years and also like 80% hated. I've never
seen somebody 95% right who's 80% hated. Who's like not just
the most flaming
who like literally tells people that they should all die. Like
I've never seen it. It's it's crazy. It never makes any sense
to me. Uh, by the way, I do I do actually know a little bit about
why he's so hated and it's going to involve some other that we
often malign on this show. Okay, guess what? Hey, Chappie, don't
talk about that guy. That guy agreed to come on this week. Announcement.
The guy who talked to Gokaro about um his techone researches.
Listen, that guy agreed to come on this week, but I think he's
reached a more like enlightened position as well. So, we'll see.
I more or less just wanted to ask
the thing I'd be interested in talking to him about. Not to cut
this off, but the techone stuff would be interesting to me because
that guy I would love to know like it seemed like in a lot of
the cases where he said this is what actually happened there,
he seemed to just be taking Teone's word for it. And from what
I recall, Tech was not producing proof for his word and that
led to him making some assertions that were like already totally
debunked, especially by Shimu's video. And I would just love
to know like
why did you feel comfortable just taking Tech's word in some
of those situations?
Maybe not the um the divorce one when that was backed up by Pink,
I guess. But like I would just love to know what the evidence
was for that other than the word of both parties and like when
it was done. Anyway, um I I would love to interrogate like that
like his thought process when he was collecting research cuz
he seems like a massive Technone fan and he says he's not. But
I don't know. We'll see how it goes. Were you about to say before
this? I have no idea. Not to cut off the the discussion on Lance
and and Jesse. Oh,
actually I was talking about something. I cut through a couple
of these things. Yeah. Um I do have like a thread over on Brianna
Woo and his and and Jesse single as well. I just going to cover
a little bit of that. Just point out that Brianna Woo totally
maligned this guy. Brianna Woo totally tried to career this guy
and
she shouldn't she really shouldn't have a career on the internet.
Um, especially dude,
Brianna Woo should be laughed out of any room of intelligent
human beings on the planet. Like, she just shouldn't be trusted
on anything. You shouldn't get nine lives on the internet, right?
I think you can forgive people. I think you can forgive people
for one or two transgressions. You should not have nine different
times you up and like try to go after somebody and totally fail
and you're totally incorrect,
right? Like that. What does malign mean? Malign.
Um, so to intentionally
discredit somebody maliciously, I would say malignment, no malignant,
no malign. I want a definition. Definition
of
Evil in nature, affect malevolence.
Oh, verb. Speak about someone in a spitefully critical manner.
Don't you dare malign her in my presence. Uh, similar. Defame,
slander, liel, smear. Doesn't Woo support Jesse now? I literally
wouldn't care. I literally wouldn't care. I literally wouldn't
care. I don't listen. You can give people time to change. They
can be wrong on something they can update. They can be wrong
on something multiple times and update. But to be wrong on things
for years and years and years and try to destroy people over
who call you out as wrong and make good arguments for why you're
wrong, you need to go away. You need to go away permanently from
the internet. Okay. It's ridiculous. as I've gotten more in >> say
anybody who like openly associates with Brianna Woo at this point
is probably also
like very very openly I which calls into question I don't know
why Taftage I think Taftage did a show with her for a while I
don't know why Taftage would do a show with her like Brianna
Woo was just openly one of the most spiteful on the internet
but anyway >> into it since after the firestorm in my Atlantic
article I had like a little bit of a we need a better term than
red pill because it didn't it didn't make me conservative it
didn't make in in favor of the bands, but I got obsessed with
these studies in a way I did for my first book, which is on non-gender
stuff where like you read about something where there's a scientific
consensus and you read study after study and you're just like
these are bad studies. And to me, it's like pretty So I I in
my first book, I wrote about something called power posing, which
is when you stand like this with your arms out and it supposedly
makes you a better and more effective negotiator and the research
is pretty bad. It's like, so what? What's the harm of that? To
me, if there's bad research about 14 and 15 year olds with a
lot of mental health coorbidities, going on hormones or getting
surgery in some cases, that's higher stakes. And I think I got
annoyed at the extent to which people were, in my view, being
pretty misleading about this subject. Um, now I will say I'm
working on a book about this after the book comes out. I would
definitely like to move on because this is a toxic subject. But
yeah, at this point I've written a lot on it cuz I think it's
an interesting subject where there aren't a lot of left of center
journalists um covering it in what I think is a respectful way.
Although I know you you disagree with
>> Yeah. But do you have like a number? I'm just curious
because like I I could I I found you know the one article in
the Atlantic. I found seven in the New York Mag. Uh three in
Medium, two penny pieces in New York Times, three articles in
Unheard, three articles for Dispatch, one article for Spectator.
Um and then >> so New York Wait, New York magazine. You're
you're including like my interview with Laura Jane Grace against
the bathroom bills. You're including anything I've written that
I mean whatever. Yeah, I've >> But I'm just saying on the
topic I'm not saying whether or not the the the coverage I'm
just saying that you you >> I mean so basically Lance is
saying you're obsessed. He's doing the you're obsessed argument
and I'm guessing on the bathroom bill I'm guessing on some of
these things Jesse would just be straight up arguing on behalf
of trans people, right? On behalf of trans rights because he's
done that quite a lot actually. He happens to be like more of
an expert on the like youth gender medicine stuff, but he does
argue on behalf of like trans rights on other topics as well.
And so he just says like wait this thing on the bathroom bill
where he almost certainly took trans people's side just goes
yeah I mean just anything where you're talking it's like okay
I guess >> written
obsessed >> pieces on this right
>> including random newsletter articles there's probably
dozens by this point. The weird thing is
um and I don't even I don't even like need to call this out that
heavily, but I remember when um when Desi was like sort of getting
close to Briana Woo, his opinion flipped on Jesse Singal, and
I remember him saying explicitly once about Jesse. He's like,
I don't know. I don't know about Jesse. Jesse seems pretty obsessed
with trans people. I guess he seems pretty obsessed. I wonder
who was talking to him that got him to think that cuz obviously
he wasn't looking into that himself. But I wonder who was like
sending him stuff that made him think that Jesse was like super
obsessed with trans people like in terms of he would make that
argument when that argument has been used against him so much.
I don't know. It was very weird. >> Okay. Um then I guess
for a topic that you've concentrated so much on, how many people
yearly in the United States are receiving, you know, children,
youth are receiving puberty blockers or things like top surgery?
>> We don't know there. I know you you're going to reference
a study that came out recently based on like insurance billings,
but so much of it is done through private insurance. I don't
think we know. I I don't think this is like when I see gender
critical types like they'll use a term like this is like gay
genocide, like the gays are being genocided and turned trans.
I don't I don't go in for any of that. Um I think there's enough
kids and the issues are interesting enough that it's a worthwhile
subject for journalism. And >> can obsess equal informed?
Almost certainly. But like no, no, no. He didn't mean it that
way. No, he didn't mean it that way. He definitely meant in like
an unhealthy way. >> That's what mainstream journalism
has decided. You know, what not and no disrespect to you, but
like the major outlets, The Economists, Reuters, The Atlantic,
the New York Times, maybe, you know, I know we've been accused
of a moral panic, but I think a lot of people think it's an interesting
issue, especially because so many parents are dealing with this
and trying to figure out what to do. Um, >> but I mean,
for a topic that you've written so much about, you probably want
to know how many >> I wish we had better. I wish we had
better data. Yeah, >> but you don't you don't agree with
the data. I know you just referenced that study, right? Like
I'm not trying to bring this stuff up as a gotcha. It's more
to understand the psychology behind this because again, if it's
something that is not occurring to a massive percentage of kids,
say like 0.1% of kids are actually receiving it. Like so for
that data that we're we're talking about from, you know, the
Komodo Health study, um it it shows that in 2021, what is it?
Puberty blockers, 1,390 kids were on it. 2020, 1,11 kids were
on it. for top surgeries 2021 282 kids were on it 2020 256 kids
got top surgeries >> you know in I don't I don't have better
data data to offer you I'll just say
the claim that only a thousand kids in the whole country are
on puberty blockers makes just it doesn't doesn't make sense
to me in part because there's like in yeah but again I don't
I don't have like data to >> there's way more kids who
are on hormone replacement therapy but there's I'd say a smaller
amount of kids who are on puberty blockers both because of the
controversy surrounding it and and the the fact that this is
something that's supposed to be temporary, right? Like my understanding
is you go into people lot for a short period of time before you're
put on to hormone replacement therapy. >> Yeah. Yeah. And
a lot of kids might I I didn't mean to talk over you, but a lot
of kids might end up at a clinic and >> is that a cut?
I don't even know if it was cut. I wasn't paying close enough
attention there. >> Hold on. >> Say like 0.1% of
kids are actually receiving it. Like 90 kids were on it. We're
talking about from you know the mobile health uh study. Um it
shows that in 2021 when it blockers 10,39 kids were on it. 2020
1,11 kids were on it. the top surgeries 2,21 282 kids are on
it 2020 26 kids >> I don't I don't have better data to
offer you I'll just say intuitively the claim that only a thousand
kids in the whole country are on tube blockers makes just it
just doesn't make sense to me in part because there's like yeah
but again I don't I don't have like data there's more kids around
hormone replacement therapy but there's I say a smaller amount
of kids around blockers because the controversy surrounding it
and the fact that this is something that's supposed to be temporary
right like my understanding is you
can go into hormone replacement therapy >> yeah and a lot
of kids might I mean to talk about a lot of kids might end up
at a clinic at an age where uh it's too age too late for puberty
blockers >> no there's a there's no cut there >> to
do much which is what makes this like such a heartbreaking controversy
is there's a subset of kids who have this limited window uh to
pass uh I mean it's a bigger deal for male to female transition
transitioners because like testosterone is a more powerful hormone
but uh that's what I find compelling about the arguments for
early medical intervention uh that you know I it's to some trans
people not all of them it's a pretty big deal to pass and to
be able to just live as a woman um and if they don't go on blockers
they probably won't get that so that time element I think really
makes this more difficult. And look, if I if I had a kid facing
these issues who really wanted to transition, I I don't know
what the hell I would do because I I don't trust the medical
establishment on this. And but I also don't trust the people
who say these treatments should be banned or that like there's
no such thing as a trans kid, which is another common line. So
I think all I've been I've been trying to argue is that it's
complicated. I think from your point of view, it's like why the
focus on this? Why the negative stories? But I think >> yeah,
I guess I I try to understand your psychology here because honestly,
if you if you've written, you know, close to 70 articles on this
and and you've dedicated so much of your career to focusing on
this subject, I I assume because like I'm saying this in good
faith. This is not because
>> you're not particularly obsessed with say discussing
trans people or, you know, trying to profit off this topic specifically
because it's been lucrative. Then my other assertion would have
to be that you are doing this specifically um because you are
genuinely concerned about what happens if there are negative
outcomes from children who receive gender affirming care uh and
the potential side effects from that. Is is that fair? >> I
think so. I think I'm also just like >> dude uh bad empanada
is just taunting Ethan Klein tonight. Bad empanada just keeps
saying like Ethan Klein. So Ethan, if you missed it, Ethan Klein
had a really embarrassing, sad
like weirdo rant again today. Hold on, let me see it where he
like threatens all of his enemies and he's like, "I'm going to
I'm going to get you guys. I'm really going to get you guys this
time." Totally doesn't seem psychopathic at all. >> Donated
again 100 Canadian dollars and said, "Also, >> he had like
this rant tonight." And in it, he like threatens bad empanada,
you see. Yeah, but Demier's not real. Bad empanada would just
say that and have nothing, by the way. He would just say it to
like [__] with people. >> So, as a new dad,
if CPS was cold on her, love y'all. Gloves off. Go get >> Thank
you, brother. And I appreciate that. Don't know. And I hope people
bear in mind,
never forget as this war rages
Um, just remember why I'm doing this.
>> just remember,
you know what I mean? I'm focused and uh I'm coming. >> Why
is he doing it? Hold on. Why is he doing it?
>> You know, and I made some promises early
and and I'm going to fulfill them all. You know, there's a there's
an order of operation. We're going down the line. If you thought
I was joking, I hope those three copyright lawsuits put that
thought to rest because >> we're going to we're just going
to sue way more people, guys. We're going to sue way more people.
>> Everyone one of you that I said I'm coming for that
I hold responsible. Guess what? It's only a matter of time.
>> don't worry. I'll get to you before the statute of limitation
ends. Remember how confident Denims was? Oh, really? You're going
to sue me? Where's the lawsuit? I'm waiting.
>> Yeah, it was over. Wasn't that when he said he was going
to sue her for defamation
and he would look like a total suing her for defamation? Why
does he It's just so dishonest, right? That was clearly what
it was about. It was about defamation. And you are going to sue
her for defamation. >> She does like this. >> Well,
wait's over. So, keep waiting. Enjoy. Enjoy the last moments
of peace you have out there to the I'll say I'm going to say
it. Noah Samson, I didn't forget about you, scumbag. Daddy's
watching and taking >> Does this does this work on people?
Do people think this is cool for some reason that this guy's
like 40 and he just goes on the internet and he's like threatening
people. I'm going to get you. I'm going to get you. I'm going
to get you. Noah Samson guy who made a video on me. You made
a YouTube video about me. I'm going to get you. I'm going to
get you. How does this not just sound like disgusting to most
people? He just sounds like such a loser. like an embarrassing
like this is like your dad who's like trying to skateboard at
40 and like trying to hang out with you and your friends and
you're like dude go do something normal. Stop being a weirdo.
Why are you being such a weirdo? Just off weirdoing notes. Okay.
And don't worry, you can. Okay. You know what? And also there's
someone else special out there that thinks that they're safe
and sound. Bad empanada. You're not. I promise you I'd find you.
And uh a promise is a promise. >> All right. Is Bad Empanada
not like openly doxed and found? And everyone does anyone not
know who Bad Empanada is? I feel like I've seen Bad Empanada's
name referenced on Ethan's show. Like full name and face. I'm
pretty sure literally everyone knows who Bad Empanada is. Essentially,
everyone knows. He won't threaten bad empanada because he's the
Joker. He just threatened Bad Empanada. He just threatened him.
Literally, he just threat he literally just threatened him. >> I
promise you I'd find you. Also, there's someone else special
out there that thinks that they're safe and sound. Bad empanada,
you're not. I promise you I'd find you. And uh
>> A promise is a promise. >> He said he could sue
Bad Empanada tomorrow if he wanted. So Bad Empanado went on Bad
Empanado went and uh started laughing at Ethan Klein publicly.
Hold on. Where is this?
Give me a second. What was it? What did he say? Wasn't he Was
he talking about how like um All right, here's one. Here's another
one. See how these go. Okay. In Argentina, it costs like $2,000
max to defend yourself in a civil suit. Lawyer charge flat fees.
I'd gladly pay that much just to have a court rule on whether
or not Ethan Klein can be called a based on the available evidence.
Laauo. Ethan's like, "Oh man, we're going to find you. Everyone
knows where I am. You could literally file a suit against me
tomorrow. The only reason you're not doing is because you're
worried about the implications of a court ruling you can be called.
Are there a max damages or anything if you hypothetically lost?"
$25.
Is that real? Anyone who intentionally dishonors or discredits
a specific natural person. What does natural person mean? Oh,
commission of a detailed crime. So, no less than 1500 pesos and
20,000 pesos. So, 20,000 Oh, Argentina's money is like super
like giga inflated, isn't it? So, apparently it's like 25 bucks.
So,
that's not the conversion rate. No.
No. I think that's just Argentina's money being worth nothing,
right? I think it's just Yeah, their money is worth literally
nothing. So, Oh, boy. Is there one more thing here? Uh, there's
these ones. Hold on. There was one more. Dude, what is happening?
Wait, what? Oh, man. I have not caught up on Twitter tonight.
Is Taylor Loren trying to dox people?
Porter Beller, can you tell me what's going on with Porter with
Taylor Loren's and uh in DMs? Taylor Loren and Bad and Panata?
Cuz I don't know what's going on. Okay. I feel like there's I
feel like is popping off. Okay. Is popping off on Twitter right
now. $20,000 20,000 pesos equals 1591. Okay. They're literally
doxing her. Why is it just dox wars? I'm so glad I got out of
this. Everyone docks in everyone. It's weird, dude. All right,
whatever. Go back to the controversy. So, again, some of the
subjects in my book, it was like the implicit association test,
power posing, this army PTSD program uh that in the states we
spent like $300 million on for all of those. You could say how
many people does this affect in the grand scheme thing of things.
And I'd say not not every journalist writes like what's the most
pressing issue right now is probably what's going on in the Democratic
Republic of the Congo. We're not talking about that or or like
there's all these hot spots. There's all this stuff we know nothing
about. That's just not really how journalists decide what to
cover in part because when we find a niche now you mentioned
profiting off it. Um
I think the kinds of study critiques I do are very dry and boring
but useful. Uh, and I think the profit maximizing way to go about
this is to just be transphobic, to go the sort of libs of Tik
Tok route or the okay groomer route. And I think it's really
important to point out that this is a medical controversy. And
if I if I if I question the medical protocols in place or the
American Medical Association, that that is not denying that trans
people exist or that they deserve access to quality healthcare.
And I it's been annoying because I I think that's a really important
point and it's like both sides disagree with that. Like you have
the left saying no that means you hate trans people. You want
them to die. You have the right saying like why are you acknowledging
trans people exist at all. Um and I would you know I host a podcast.
I express opinions. But I do do think just like being a science
journalist who tries to get >> I don't know if like the
right really hates him as much as he says. I feel like a lot
of people in the right kind of ignore the fact that he supports
trans people and only look at the fact that he
when he's like, "Oh, the right is like, why do you why do you
even acknowledge trans people exist?" I don't think any right-wingers
ever said that to him. I think they just ask him about why d
why children drans, why child youth uh sorry, why youth gender
medicine is bad, right? I think that's a weird misrepresentation.
truth is important here. But I I >> but ultimately those
lanes are already pretty well occupied by people who, you know,
aren't aren't cowardly about their beliefs. They wear their hearts
on their chests and they will say things like Michael Nolles
does, right? That, you know, we want to eradicate transgenderism
from society. I think that you found >> Okay. Taylor Ren's
getting stalked by some rando in the H3 Facebook community. She
posts all group admins and ask for IDs. Banana single signal
boosts these and gets all three people doxed. H3 threatens doxing
the Gatfumodor account on his IG story. They go private on Twitter
and then Dan sends all of all of Gat Fumodor's info to Ethan.
I feel very little empathy for the Gat Fumodor person because
they apparently like threatened Dan too. Like they apparently
tried to menace Dan with some like Doc's address or something
like that. Unless I misread that thread from yesterday. I believe
that's what they tried to do. That's like okay. You decided to
go to doc wars with D. Good luck. Good luck. I'm not I'm not
taking yours out on anything. You if you fire the first shot,
you uh you around, buddy. You around, you're going to find out
>> something that's uh a little bit more unique and that
you can actually approach these topics from a standpoint where
people on the right could then use the information that you put
out there because it's not coming from a right-wing or a farright
voice. It's coming from someone who identifies as a center or
a center leftist. >> Uh I don't think Dan should dox him
is like a appropriate. I would just say if you try to dox Dan,
good luck. Um, you're going to get reciprocation. It's going to
be bad for you, but good luck. >> Right. So, that that
would be a unique lane in terms of uh if that was in fact something
that you were doing for >> right? So, the idea is that
I'm I'm seeking to have my ideas laundered and used by like Trump
or whatever. >> Uh, not seeking to. I'm saying that that
would be something that not a lot of other people approach it
from that angle specifically. right now I'm not making that accusation
but I'm saying then if that's not the case then the the other
answer is that this is something that obviously outside of the
controversy and outside of the fact that it's you know been a
highly discussed topic your interest primarily is obviously to
make sure that again children who are receiving forms of gender
affirming care uh whether they be you know surgical procedures
uh stuff of that nature uh are not making lifechanging decision
>> bro what the bro I'm like sorry I'm like looking at
the H3 subreddit right now in the um what is it? The leftovers
H3 subreddit just trying to catch up on this stuff. It's like
some dude in a Facebook group posting
Taylor Loren's like like all of her info.
that's crazy. I think the big one is um
I think the big one is her age. She's been like hiding her age
online.
>> So that's that's like the big one. She like her name
is Taylor Loren. That's not unknown.
But uh what is this? In today's age of Oh, hold on. Hold on.
So, we got uh Skulls. Yafumodor says, "Yes, it's terrible that
Ethan did this to his own children. Maybe someone should consider
contacting CPS. That's a very mean thing to tweet." It's a pretty
mean thing to tweet right there. In today's nearly today's age
of rapidly improving technology, anonymity is nearly impossible
to maintain, even for a throwaway Twitter account. For example,
the operator behind this account is a 37-year-old single male
who's currently unemployed and living with his parents named
DB. You don't need to know his name. He just needs to know I
that I do. This person is clearly down and out. And it's a shame
that instead of improving his life, he's dedicated all his time
and energy into snarking strangers on the internet. Now, as a
result of his unforgivable attacks on my family, his outlook
is even more bleak. He's facing down a lifetime of soulcrushing
debt and litigation. He doesn't have a wage now, but if he does
ever crawl out of his mother's yellow yellow old basement, I'll
be garnishing every cent he earns for the rest of his life. Wow,
this guy is so cool. He's so cool. He's totally not a complete
and utter degenerate loser. Absolutely not. Absolutely not. It
would be so cool if Elon Musk used his vast amount of money to
just start doxing and suing random leftists on Twitter, wouldn't
it? Wouldn't that be cool? Wouldn't we think that was awesome
if Elon Musk took all of the people who ever said something negative
about him on uh on Twitter and just started suing those people?
Wouldn't that be awesome? Wouldn't we love to live in that world?
Anybody who criticizes Elon Musk is now getting sued. Wouldn't
that be cool?
>> I just don't I just wish people could like look at this
and go, "Oh yeah, I wouldn't really like this." Now, this Gat
Fumador guy is like unhinged. He is a total loser. But this comment,
if you're like doxing him for this comment, this is just a mean
comment. Grow up, loser. Block. Ask the people who are sending
you the he's saying about you to block him.
Just block, bro. Omfg's pro. You You I know you're like so proud
of advertising your 70 IQ here, but I just I Please try to reverse
the roles for the love of God. Pretend pretend Train Wrecks had
a point on anything and just try to reverse the roles. It's so
sad watching this. It's so sad. I don't know why you watch me
and you like hear the actual arguments against this and then
you can just be like, "No, get him, Ethan. Get him."
Yeah, I love I love a woman could come after me. I love it. >> I
just I wish I wish there was any thought process there, but I
realize there's not. It's fine. It's genuinely depressing. Actually,
it's not really fine, but there are a handful of attack dogs
that operate similarly on Twitter for the benefit of Assam Taylor
Loren. They know who they are. I have the time and money to find
each and every one of you. As you have uh re as you have reveled
in your anonymity as a mean to defame me as a means to defame
me and attack my family and children. I now revel in shining
a light into the pathetic corner of the internet where you exist.
I'm coming for all of you. In the meantime, D, you'll be hearing
more from me soon. Sophia, thank you for the 18 months. Thank
you, Sophia.
In the meantime, D, you'll be hearing from me soon. I have the
honor to be your obedient servant, Ethan Klein. I don't even
know what this means. What's up with Zionist? It's like Ethan
Klein constantly doing false flags.
>> Uh it's so easy to be like It's so easy to be like to
It's so easy to be like to say I don't agree with this sort of
harassment or involving his kids and still call him a Zionist
piece of y'all need to touch grass if you're out researching
if he faked that or not. Okay. Do not agree with Ethan Klein
harassing himself and his children for sympathy. Yeah, this person
is schizophrenic. I just I don't know what the point of engaging
with them is.
Um, especially especially if they have a point here if they're
lying maliciously.
>> You could sue them. I don't know why you'd have to dox
them publicly and sue them, but you could sue them.
>> By the way, if he just keeps this to like lawsuits against
people who have like broken the law against them, that's maybe
fine. But things where it's just they're talking like the previous
tweet where he freaked the out, that one, no go. It's a no-go
on that one. Okay.
this one. If it's like a malicious lie,
I still think you let it go. I still think you just live your
life. Like, who cares?
But whatever. Ethan Klein needs to win on the internet apparently.
Dude, the the backlash to him overall at the end of this is going
to be so insane.
It's going to be hilarious. He is like actually turning into
like a Briana Woo level cow. And the backlash against him is
going to be so funny and so deserved. It's going to be It's going
to be awesome. It will be very funny. Is Brianna Woo even this
bad? I'm just talking about how like using like a frenzy where
people aren't thinking correctly to like continue to try to go
after your enemies. I think this very similar in that way. Was
she as effective? No, cuz she's But she's trying to do the same
thing. She's going for the same idea. Just wasn't very good at
it.
>> Anyway,
we go back to this debate here real quick, guys. Uh where are
we at here for time? We need three subs for another hour on the
stream. Three subs for another hour on the stream. There's a
couple different ways you could donate. It's 15 bucks. You could
donate through Kickbot. You can donate through Streamlabs. You
can gift subs. You can sub yourself. You could sub on Twitch.
You could sub Twitch Prime. Okay. There's many different ways
to gift or donate. Three subs for another hour on the stream.
15 bucks for another hour on the stream. Up to you guys if you
want to do that. We're going to continue on with this debate
for a little bit. See if anything else shakes out on Twitter
tonight. Thanks for being here, guys. Sunday night. Oh. Uh, also
if we do like two more hours, if we get the second hour here,
the last hour on the stream, maybe we do spooky Sunday video
>> decisions or uh decisions that effectively could have
a negative impact upon their life uh without having a full conversation
about the potential risks, right? Is that fair? >> Is I
just I don't look at it that way. I look at it as like I want
people to have the best most accurate information available,
especially parents. I don't really think of my work as like this
will prevent bad outcomes because I think
there's so much other information out there. I just I um >> but
okay so your concern is less about the children and more on the
parents of the children then so that the parents have access
to information on again >> well it's so in the states it's
it is in most cases the parents making the decision which >> gets
Harry
>> Jag 34 thank you for the five gifted let's that's another
hour on the stream thank you >> own way I mean I don't
know I think it's interesting I do like I said I'm like I'm uh
wearing a little bit thin on it because it's it's a tough thing
to write about and I think people would be surprised how many
very angry emails I get from the right. Um, but
yeah, I don't know. I just I sort of I stand by most of my work.
I think there's some stuff I got wrong, especially early on.
Uh, like the well 80% desistence. It's just I didn't understand
the full complexity of that literature. And in The Atlantic,
I think I was too differential to some trans rights organizations
and journalists always need to be careful about that. But yeah,
I think I'll uh I don't know. I think I'm okay with what I'm
doing. Can I ask then why it is that you've never tackled like
cosmetic surgery of youth in the >> Like a like a what?
Like a 14-year-old getting a boob job? >> Well, yeah, because
I I wanted to look that up just out of curiosity. Like the the
stats on that in in 2020 there was like 229,740
cosmetic procedures on teenagers including 3,233
breast augmentations. It seems to be something in which it's
happening at a much larger and more frequent rate uh in the US
in terms of teenagers getting you know surgeries in forms of
gender affirming care uh that effectively could have negative
outcomes and and sometimes >> gender affir gender sorry
a girl getting a boob job you're calling as gender affirming
care. >> Yeah, I'd say philosophically obviously I agree
with you probably or sorry not probably it's not medically the
same as having gender dysphoria and then trying to get treated
for gender dysphoria as a trans person. I'm not saying that at
all. What what I am saying though that
>> So why haven't I read I mean to me that's such like
a it's such a no-brainer that that's
a bad idea for a girl. No, I don't I would I would want to dig
into those stats and know how many of those are purely cosmetic.
Uh I think in some cases like cosmetic overlaps with functional
stuff and there might be something wrong but >> Oh yeah,
there's there's breast there's breast reduction surgeries that
are being done for medical reasons to both men and women, right?
Um but no no this is this is a massive thing in the United States.
Like, you know, there's >> Has the surf's gotten work done?
He looks very different. I doubt it. I kind of doubt it. Hold
on. Let me see here. Let me see. Let me see. Let me see. Let
me see. Let me see. Oldest. >> What exactly is putting
the word gay?
>> No, I think he just lost weight. I think that's it.
I think this guy just lost weight and that's it, right?
>> No, his nose looks the same.
Hairline looks the same. He's lost weight. That's it. articles
I I could pull from 2011 that had 8,000 women aged 13 to 19 were
undergoing breast augmentation. And that's something that's like
it's not even FDA approved. You're not supposed to get breast
implants if you're under 18 years old. So, it's something that
people are having to do off label and are being done on very
very large scales and rates and and it's not something that is
in any way talked about in the same way the discussions surrounding
trans people is and the focus on trans people. I think I think
partly it's because of that like the old journalism expression
dog bites man like dog bites man is not an interesting story.
Like to me it's so obvious that a teenage girl who hasn't yet
fully developed if this is what's happening shouldn't get a breast
job. Uh, I mean, if I would I don't know. I always get like a
little about, >> right? But if that's the way you feel
on that, wouldn't that be something that you should then be bringing
more attention to even if it isn't topical? Or does that go back
to the same thing with, you know, Canadian mining companies in
the Congo? It it's not something you think would get the same
>> So, if if if a big chunk of the >> it's like not
a cultural movement right now, what are we what are we talking
about? Yeah, this is being talked about. It's in the cultural
zeitgeist. Yeah, of course he's a journalist. He's not just going
to write about something that like matters to nobody. It's the
exact same reason. Bro, why? If genocide is such a problem to
you, Lance, why aren't you talking about what's going on in Darth
4? How many How many videos can I go? Oh, this is going to be
bad. He's probably going to have a bunch of videos on this. >> This
interview is over. I'm going to start recording. >> I just
searched Darus.
>> Do we have a ton of We got No. Oh, wait. Do we have
a bunch of things on Palestine? Oh, there's a bunch of things.
Wait, I thought I thought that genocide was bad. Isn't genocide
bad? Well, if genocide's bad and you've got all these videos
on Palestine, why don't we have any videos on four? Do black
people not matter to you, Lance? Liberal >> absolutely
disgusting. You seem kind of obsessed with Lance. You seem kind
of obsessed with
out and said, "We think." >> Oh, whoops. I spelled it wrong,
didn't I? Darur.
Oh. Oh, thank God. Thank god. That would have really uncut undercut
my point if I spelled it correctly and then everything was gone.
I would have really me up. Okay. think it's really important
these girls have breast implants and it became a fairly I mean
it sounds like it is a common practice although I'm guessing
it's more in conservative places. Um, I just think if I wrote
that, everyone would be like, "Yeah, this is obviously wrong.
This shouldn't happen." The question of, "Should there be like
>> There wouldn't be a bunch of insane leftists in his
replies being like, "You're a bigot. You're a bigot. Let a 13-year-old
have double D's, Jesse. You're a bigot. Why can't a Why can't
a 13-year-old decide to have double D's, Jesse? You sex or whatever."
Like, I wouldn't be opposed to that. But I just it's hard for
me to imagine a situation where a a 16-year-old girl would >> I
OMFG's pro literally heard me explain use like the the Palestine
argument to like actually show how Lance's argument was completely
right and then he was like he just made the argument actually
like legitimately made the argument. He just he just took the
argument that I was using to point out how what Lance was saying
was and then he said it literally. Oh boy. >> Would would
do that. >> It's very disappointing. I feel like do I I
feel like I need you to go sign up for like oiler or something's
bro to like add you need to fund me to to deal with the stress
of having to read your messages. I need like more money. It's
not worth it just for free. I'm telling you it's like not worth
it. I'm sorry. >> I think her parents are really failing
in that situation if they're approving it. Um but again, this
is something that is happening at a much higher rate, right?
I I even got into
Well, well, we do know the rates of plastic surgery on teens,
right? Because the the stats are are publicly available. So for
for >> now he's not reinforcing for example that's 44,686
teenagers got rhinoplasty
>> um that that that's an overwhelming amount of people
who are getting potentially you know life-changing surgery uh
there's eyelid surgery >> I don't I don't buy I don't buy
that comparison as much because I think rhinoplasty and double
mistctomy like rhinoplasty is less intensive but if someone if
someone floated like a I don't know it's if someone was like
no kid under 16 should get this. I would not be outraged at that
at all. Uh I think I just think like teenagers
on it then if this is something that you could say was in a comparable
category that affects way more teenagers than gender affirming
care which again when you look at it we're talking about hundreds
of kids on puberty blockers and then hundreds of or sorry maybe
it was over a thousand like 1,100 kids on puberty blockers. Then
for kids getting, you know, uh, gender affirming care related
surgeries, those numbers are are, you know, they're practically
non-existent in relation to the fact that there's like 72 million
kids in the United States. >> I mean, if we're >> Okay,
are you guys good? Do you just have to keep pointing out Jesse's
Junos? Do you guys just chill?
Do you guys just chill? Please, please chill with the nose comments
>> comparing something. >> He pointed out himself.
He pointed out that he looks like obviously.
He said it himself. We don't have to keep doing it. He called
Bercy.
He called Berscie on this. You guys could stop.
>> Like a nose job for a 16-year-old to having her breast
removed. I just think one of those is a much more serious procedure
than the other. Uh and >> but that would be a personal
decision, right? Not medical one. >> No, you're losing
the ability to breastfeed. You're losing some degree of >> Oh,
but that can happen with breast implants as well.
>> Yeah, I mean Oh, breast implants. Sorry. No, no. I I
I added that afterwards. I was previously speaking about Yeah.
But like, so if
you're say it sounds like you're saying teenagers maybe if they're
going to get a permanent medical procedure, they we need to be
careful about that and like they shouldn't be rushed into it.
>> Well, they're not rushed into it. First off, is the
thing there, right? That's a that's a myth that kids are going
through some kind of revolving door and you know, >> oh
god, he's going back to the informed consent model. still think
that it's a ridiculous assertion because no medical practitioner
is going to tell you that a kid walks in and then they're given
puberty blockers and then walks right out of the the >> but
what do you think about about the story I reported for the economist
>> dude if Lance was just median IQ he could actually make
it as a YouTuber like in a Hassan type of way all he had to do
is be median IQ
just hit the median he would have been fine
he didn't have to be world beating smart he just had to be average
where a kid walked right in and got puberty blocked records at
Children's Hospital of Los Angeles. You think she's lying or
the medical records are lying? >> No, I'm saying if it's
true that you know those are rare cases. This is this is not
the majority of the cases though, >> So you just said So
you just said it doesn't happen. Then I said it happened. You
said yes, but it doesn't happen a lot. But you don't know because
Reuters I Well, I don't know because you're talking about an
anecdote that I'm not familiar with. So obviously I have no prior
knowledge to this. But if if it is true, I am saying that I'm
saying that this is not indicative of the vast majority of people's
experiences. Again, similar to how we're writing about dransitioning
and focusing on that.
>> Are you against a 13-year-old getting puberty blockers
their first
>> Uh, it's not really what I personally feel because I'm
not an expert on this topic. It's it's what the current DSM5
requirements are, right? So, it's one of those things where like
for children, we we have to basically follow the majority consensus
of the medical community in all fields. I I I would apply this
to to anything else. By the way, I would apply this to to kids
who have appendicitis, >> So Jesse's point is just going
to be if you could identify like blatantly bad science, blatantly
bad statistics that are backing most of the youth gender care,
then do we have to trust them blindly? Do we have to say, well,
you're the experts? And even though you can't answer any of my
questions on why this data is bad, I guess we just have to trust
you. That's the whole point. >> Can I
again just like actually that's the whole point. It's the whole
point. and you are not participating in the conversation when
you continue to go back to well all the medical experts agree
or they they like broadly support this in the US or in Canada.
I'm I'm sure if Jesse looked through it and he went yeah they
do support it that's really dumb would be his answer. Like even
if they did all support it hypothetically he would still say
I need you to critically engage with the points I'm making. I
make recommendations as to whether or not your kid should be
getting uh you know a surgery to take a part of their body out
of them if if it's been infected and inflamed that could potentially
save them. I mean I I could politicize that by saying it's mutilation.
You're going to be mutilating your child's body by taking out
their appendix and then that is going to remove a part of them
forever. But ultimately I you know again this is something that
I would have to defer to the majority consensus of the scientific
>> Yeah. I the problem just for years now has been this
like I think because of the bubbles we inhabit different realities
and there's probably areas where your reality is more correct
than mine but on this one where you just sort of blindly say
this isn't how it worked. like the Reuters, the biggest investigation
in the states of how gender clinics operate was Reuters in I
think 2022 and they called up I forget how many eight or 10 of
the biggest multi-disiplinary gender clinics and they all said
we'll give we'll give puberty blockers on the first session now
they said in cases where we feel comfortable with it but that's
like a serious liberalization of the so-called Dutch protocol
where you you go through you jump through some hoops you even
go on blockers and maybe that's too many hoops but >> sorry
your assertion is that the majority of kids who walk into clinics
are given puberty blockers on the first >> I never said
the I never said the majority you said you said this is something
that doesn't happen and I said according to the best investigation
we have it routinely happens because all these clinics say yes
we do that >> So it routinely happens as in so not the
majority but it can happen and has happened before >> with
some regularity at the biggest multi-disiplinary gender clinics.
Yeah. like their regular practice is a kid shows up for the first
appointment they send them out >> again but okay so this
is not how we talk about any other topic in relation to children's
healthcare right like I I wouldn't specifically be like there
are cases probably in which doctors are prescribing uh medications
like aderall for for children uh which could be dangerous and
they shouldn't have done that and they had negative outcomes
I'm sure that happens of course we're talking no but I say that
there just >> again if you had data in a study for aderall
in kids that was like the data for for um gender affirming care,
gender youth medicine, if you had similar data, the FDA would
say, "No, no, no, no. Go back and redo your study." This the
study is totally unacceptable. It's >> believe millions
of children, what like 72 million in the United States, right?
There's going to be obviously examples of of doctors who are
not following the the proper ethical protocol. I I don't have
control over that or whether or not that happens. Yeah, but that
that doesn't but that doesn't then change whether or not people
should have access to gender affirming care or healthcare in
general based on bad practitioners. >> No, nor and I haven't
argued otherwise. But but you're saying there hasn't been a debate
over whether kids are being overprescribed at all. Hasn't that
been a massive debate? >> I never said that there hasn't
been a debate. I'm saying that there could be cases there could
be cases in which >> Yeah. His point was that if you have
somebody who is like overprescribing or prescribing badly and
there are bad outcomes for one kid, it doesn't mean that all
kids should be banned from having aderall. That's what it means.
>> Are prescribed at all when they >> which is like
a fine argument, but the issue is aderall is not the same. Aderal
is like a compound that's been tested, right? This would be like
arh what would be the counterargument to this? or sorry, what
would be this is like people this is the same argument that people
do when they're like well no no puberty blockers are safe and
it's like yeah I understand puberty blockers are approved for
treatment of some diseases that doesn't necessarily mean they're
safe and it doesn't necessarily mean that when those diseases
aren't present they previously been tested on that like they're
handled well by the body there's like a whole bunch of uh what
would you call it like um there's a whole bunch of conflicting
or conflicting contraindicating factors a whole bunch of like
other factors that could go and and make this bad right that
you have to address aderall isn't arrested a normal isn't arresting
a normal development process. Yeah, exactly. That's also true.
And I think the idea that with puberty blockers specifically,
you could just restart them that they just pause. I think that's
been broadly disproven, like almost entirely disproven, that's
like nothing, that's something nobody even argues anymore. >> They
need to be prescribed aderall, right? And and in >> which
led to a massive debate in the states, not just Adderall, but
everything from like antiscychotics, anti-anx, like we have a
huge debate. This this is the only pediatric medical issue where
for a while there wasn't debate. Like I sort of feel like your
side lost and the debates broken out into the open. But you're
I I think your point you're making the opposite. >> You
keep saying I I'm not entirely sure what you mean. Do you mean
do you mean leftists? Is is that it just like >> No, no.
You've you've I assume you don't consider us to be in agreement
about this stuff. >> But what's stuff >> you think
these treatments Oh, gender >> Oh, a bunch of different
Yeah, of course not. No, we're we're diametrically opposed on
this. I I I personally >> What would you What would you
call either
blank
of that diametric opposition? What would you call that? What
would be the word? Either blank of that diametric diametric opposition
where that line's drawn. You're diametrically opposed. What would
you call You're on You're on one blank. What would you call the
other blank? >> What What are we doing?
>> Well, no. I'm on the side of the majority of the scientific
consensus on this. There's there's really no point in me being
a non-scientist coming forward to you and saying like again this
is one of the the the points of you trying to say like you don't
even know what informed consent means because I'm not a doctor
and this is not my area of expertise. This is something that
I would defer to again the majority of the scientific community
if if the majority of the scientific >> as long as they
were as long as it wasn't a Swedish doctor, a Finnish doctor,
a Norwegian doctor in which case you would disagree. >> Once
again, anecdotes and isolated examples though, right? Like again,
if it's something,
>> right? But there there can be indicate there can be
moments in time where there's going to be a single doctor who
comes forward and says, "Hey, by the way, I'm a whistleblower.
I have to say this. We've been giving kids puberty blockers way
too fast." Of course, that's going to happen. There's billions
of humans on the planet, right? In the case of should this
Wait, if he came out and said that and nobody else agreed, would
would entire country's policy change or of guys guys of course
there are billions of humans on the planet? Of course, some random
human being who happened to be a doctor who happened to work
in gender medicine would happen to say, "Oh, we've been to they'd
happen to say this exact sentence possibly at the cost of their
career or some malpractice like lawsuit or you know, if you're
lying about medical research, you'd probably lose your license
or something, right? This guy's willing to put his reputation
on the line to go, "Hey, I'm blowing the whistle here." No, that's
policy, not antidotes. I think you mean anecdotes. >> should
we restrict the ability for people to have access to healthcare,
which in my opinion is restricting their
reset my headphones really quickly. Give me a sec.
>> Ability uh to have human rights. I I believe that a
trans person should have access to healthcare just as a sis person
should. So in that case, >> that's a such a worthless nothing
statement. Yes, Jesse's arguing that we should take healthcare
away from trans people. Like, everything has to be like this
moralized, panic-causing
statement, right? You're you're removing healthcare from trans
people. I mean, you're removing a tiny subset of healthare from
certain trans people at a certain age. >> I would again,
because it's not my area of expertise, defer to the majority
consensus of the scientific community on that one. In Canada,
it is it is every major medical association as it is in the United
States. Now, as you said, >> take a shot. Every time he
completely ignores the articles that Jesse's written, every time
he goes, I'm just going to defer to the medical experts.
Okay, just take a shot. He's not paying >> That could change.
You know, you could start to have a a reversal of this in the
same way United Kingdom, right? Where now even the bathroom uh
debate has been reignited. I'm not saying that political movements
aren't going to push for an agenda in this regard.
>> Yeah. I I guess I just don't understand when you exhibit
deference to the experts and when you don't because it sounds
like it's sort of a continentally based. So like North American
experts, whatever they say you believe. European experts, no
not so much. Well, when you keep bringing up European experts,
right, the vast majority, would you sorry, you make an assertion
that the vast majority of uh experts on the topic, including
the entirety of the medical community in in Europe, disagrees
with with the Canadian and the American medical associations.
>> Well,
well, there's there's a part of what makes this complicated is
like American healthcare sucks and is politicized. So, right
now, the position of the American government and the healthcare
experts in it is that these treatments are bad. We can set that
aside. My point is Finland, Sweden, Norway, the UK all did what
in other situations would be considered like normal review processes
pretty in-depth and they all none of them came to the conclusion
like these treatments are horrible, but they all came to the
conclusion that the evidence really sucks and they all really
made their policies in those countries more conservative. And
when you say you don't trust their judgment, but you do trust
the American Medical Association's judgment, I just don't get
why.
So I'm saying I trust the broad consensus of the scientific community
which as of now again recording this still I I don't see an overwhelming
amount of the scientific community on this topic. I I see isolated
examples and politicized movements within uh a series of countries
that you're now trying to use as a justification for saying if
it's happening there it could happen here or it will happen here.
It's only a matter of time. >> What's up? watching the
Jesse Singal Lance from the surfs trans debate
couple weeks ago. What is it? No, not even a couple weeks ago.
Couple days ago. >> And I'm not going to disagree with
the fact that especially under Trump and his current regime that
there's obviously going to be a push back and there already is
uh towards restricting the rights of access to healthcare for
children. That is a by the way a great argument from Jesse that
I didn't really pick up on or highlight and should have is hey
um the federal government or like basically politicians in general
can have a massive effect on what these organizations these American
medical organizations are the ones are going to say and if they
put their thumb in the scale maybe they can get them to flip.
If Trump could get everybody to flip and say transgender people
don't exist would that mean transgender people don't exist would
we just have to defer to the all of these organizations?
Would we just go, "Oh, yeah. Actually, these organizations are
all correct with no critical thought, no engagement at all."
I kind of feel like you would say no. >> children, what
what what they require is again people to cherrypick data and
people to cherrypick examples or to cherrypick studies and then
use those as a justification for again doing political action
against a persecuted and minority group in the same way that
this was happening to say gay people prior to trans people. And
and one of the reasons why I think again what what you do is
particularly insidious is because you are giving them the ability
uh to say that this is not just coming from the right that there
are authors say like Jesse Singal who are capable of demonstrating
that hey there there are cracks in these so-called
uh you know general consensus there there are opportunities for
people to to find you know disagreements.
Um like >> so your your problem is with a journalist saying
there's cracks in a consensus cuz you're so confident that that
consensus is correct basically. That's what you're saying or
>> no? Uh uh more just the just asking questions of it
all, right? Like like why can't we just ask questions? To me,
I I think if you had a genuine curiosity on this, unless you
want to push a political agenda, then the breadth of information,
including the overwhelming amount of studies on this topic, and
yes, there are isolated studies that you can pull out as as you
know, I've debated Tim P on this topic. I've spoken to other
people. They always have this the Swedish study actually disagrees
with you. uh you know I I can pull up this Dutch study that I
think was misinterpreted but if it's the overwhelming amount
of studies or the meta analysis of studies or or the general
consensus of the scientific community still at this point then
what you're saying you could pull up isolated examples of other
countries where things are more dracon
>> I should have had a counter for how many times he's
going to make this argument I should have had a counter I just
should have had a counterion >> right like Uganda
if I if I went to Uganda you know there would be very very harsh
penalties for either being a or being a that to me is not going
to be >> what are they disagreeing on um Jesse Singal is
a like basically really wellressearched journalist who focuses
who used to focus on basically like bad science research bad
scientific research and now is narrowed into like youth transgender
medicine like youth genders youth genders medicine as like a
field where there was a lot of malfeasants and research and he's
written a couple articles on it and now Lance is arguing that
like yeah no you're wrong about everything you've written And
the premise of Jesse's articles is that medical research has
basically been like green lit even though it's bad based on bad
data in the US to allow certain things like puberty blockers
some other parts of basically the like how quickly you can get
somebody through to actually being on hormones in terms of gender
like youth gender medicine in the US. That stuff's been green
lit too fast. He's disagreeing with the medical organizations.
And Lance's argument is I defer to the medical organizations.
If that's your position, you're saying, "I don't want to argue."
Right? He's using that as an argument. That's not just like he
wants to argue over whether or not you should agree. He's saying
that is an argument. Full stop. I don't need to have any other
conversation. Now, if you just read any of Jesse's articles,
you would know that his point is that that is what we have to
debate. So, when you say that as if it's an argument, you are
basically saying, "I don't know what you're talking about. I've
never read one of your articles despite citing them. And I am
ba broadly like incapable of conversation." So that's what Lance
keeps doing over and over and over again and it's uh it's got
to be weighing on Jesse a little bit at this point because it's
happened repeatedly. >> Be reflective of whether or not
we should be advocating for people's healthcare here domestically
in Canada. But I think we should obviously uh listen to the international
community when it comes to their scientific conclusions on this
topic. >> Okay. But you're just saying in this in these
particular four cases of Finland, Norway, Sweden, the UK, these
four happen to be politicized. So we can safely either disregard
them or >> disling. Thanks for the $5.
>> I'm not disregarding them, but but I'm saying uh but
but why are you using that as a way to discount your own country's
scientific consensus on this? My own country's scientific consensus
of this as of a few weeks ago is that is the HHS report which
is the whole point is this stuff gets politicized institutions
I mean that what who's so >> okay so
but but you're not answer okay so see you just avoided the question
right there Jesse because there so the majority of the medical
>> wait there's no way there's no way there's no way that
Lance is going to say what Jesse says well because this is my
country is the HHS report and he's going to go wait hold on you
can't just defer to a report. I'm asking your >> Communities,
every major medical association in the United States agrees on
this topic. And yet you're like, well, no, we're moving in an
opposite direction. Here's a report coming out. Is that the one
that was commissioned or or overseen by Robert F. Kennedy? Is
that the same one? >> Well, I mean, he said the HHS report.
Robert Kennedy is the director, the head of the N the HHS. I
would assume it's the one ordered by Robert Kennedy. >> His
HHS. Yeah. But I think Reuters
Well, I don't know because we're at I think >> other important
areas of functioning. So, what you just read the DS I was like
I don't believe once this entire >> Hold on. I just clicked
I just clicked like an idiot. Hold on. Uh Kennedy
110 not >> that was commissioned or or overseen by Robert's
person. Doesn't he believe that microplastics
cause trans people? Like doesn't he have a >> RFK RFK Jr.
is a crank? The the point I'm trying to get at here is >> then
how is that
>> ah huge W for Lance Jesse Singal basically just endorse
Robert F. Kennedy by saying he's a crank. Oh my god. >> Legitimate
example of this. Like how's how is that a valid thing to bring
up? When I'm saying in your own country the majority consensus
is is centered around >> When you say majority consensus
you're talking about a handful of statements being that have
been put out by different organizations. Those statements have
actual content. It's not like a a golden plate handed down by
God. So what you do if you're a journalist or if you're a scientist
is you read those statements and you evaluate them and you see
if they make sense. And one thing you do is you see if the citations
point to studies
defending the claim being made. And the folks who have looked
at that question of if these guidelines are good, these were
the Cass folks, although it's technically an independent team
separate from Cass. Uh they don't think the guidelines are good.
And and I think what happens sometimes, and we've seen this happen
in the past, is that doctors get very excited about a new treatment
and they're trying to do the right thing. They're trying to help
kids or save kids lives or prevent
and they get out over their skis and they make claims they can't
defend. If uh I swear to God if we come out after this and Lance
says, "A gee shucks, Jesse. I don't know. I just feel like the
majority of medical organizations in the United States and Canada
seem to all be in alignment on this." If he says that, I may
put a hole in one of my monitors. So, you guys literally will
have to pay for that. Okay? I'm letting you know now that I will
be doing a donation goal for a new monitor if he does that. And
so, when you know Joanna Olsen Kennedy, who's she's the one who
got sued, whose story I wrote about for The Economist, when she
says she has never given puberty blockers to a kid for whom it
was the wrong choice. So, she's suggesting she has an 100% batting
average. Um, I think the right thing for a journalist or
Will Lance understand? Can Lance see that Jesse has just up massively?
First Jesse of the debate. Okay. 100% batt 100 batting average.
Okay. He said 100% batting average, so I can't even do it. [__]
Never mind. Ah, he said a thousand. He said 100%. But a batting
average is typically out of a thousand, right? You typically
bat out of a thousand. But he said 100%. And so it doesn't even
>> someone who actually cares about trans people to do
is be like, >> could that really be true that this doctor
is so infallible that in the hundreds of times she's given these
treatments, she's never been wrong. And I I think you're >> I
thought we could get him, but then I thought about what he said.
>> Granting
them boundless deference to these American and Canadian professional
groups. Uh while
I don't know I don't know what your stance is on the eur European
efforts, which I think were more scientific, but um I guess that's
the problem here. So you believe the cast review was more scientific
in >> than what? Than what? >> Than than than the
the Canadian-American counterparts and consensus on this
>> but you're you're lumping. Okay. So for example, the
one I know the most about is the American Academy of Pediatrics.
That was just like that was a guy. It was a guy. Do I think a
guy's views on this uh should be weighed more heavily than a
handful of of York University systematic reviews? No, of course
not. You do? You think Jason Raferty gets to beat all these independent
systematic
>> But when you say a guy, because again you you'll then
point to an anecdote of someone where it's like here's an example
of a you know clinic. >> I'm describing I'm describing
the statement you're defending. It was written by a guy named
Jason Raffford who who I think was a psychiatric resident at
the time. He was a guy. That's what it says in the paper. You're
saying that you trust that one guy more than the teams that did
these systematic reviews at um I always mix up University of
York and York University, whichever the British one is. The you're
saying >> but in in this case, is it not reflective of
the statement by the organization itself or it doesn't speak
for it? His statement is independent of the organization or or
it is representative of the organization. >> There's a
weird line at the bottom that says I can pull it up just to make
sure I'm being accurate about this. I also got to go in like
10 minutes. We said we're doing our Rafferty statement. >> Oh.
All right. Well, then can link that thing. I do want to talk
to you about one or two quick things then that we haven't actually
brought up. >> Yeah, let me just read this one sentence
and then I'll I'll move on. Um,
policy statements.
>> Dr. Rafferty conceptualized the statement, drafted the
initial manuscript, reviewed and revised the manuscript, approved
the final manuscript as submitted, and agrees to be accountable
for all aspects of the work. It's a very strange statement and
that I that's why I would question why you would
say that we should pay more you know um view this as more believable
than a handful of independently conducted conducted systematic
reviews >> simply because again it's something >> it's
a guy and there's no purpose >> right but but you just
don't like the way the worded
>> but you just don't like the because it sounds strange
>> but there's also there's there's
man it would take an hour for us to talk about the differences
between systematic reviews and policy statements. Ask ask whatever
you want to ask cuz we don't have that much time left. >> Okay.
Um I just want to quickly see that this was something that you
still believe, but in a debate that you had with Jangle Science
Lab on July 1st, 2020, you said it. I'm going to quote you here.
Gender dysphoria is listed in the DSM. Maybe it shouldn't be,
but as of now, gender dysphoria itself is a mental illness. Maybe
we'll look back and say that it shouldn't have been. Still stand
by that statement. >> Yeah, the DSM5 lists gender dysphoria
as a mental illness. Yeah, they were they've changed it from
gender identity disorder to gender dysphoria partly because that
would make it sound less stigmatizing or whatever, but it's listed
alongside all the Yeah. Now, >> it's it's not listed as
mental illness though that I mean to do that is something that
right-wingers do I think specifically to be able to again like
you just mentioned
>> Oh, please for the love of God. For the love of God,
>> I need Okay, never mind. Never mind. Never mind. Couldn't
he just defer? I feel like I feel like I wouldn't be able to
help but defer even lie just to say listen I wouldn't personally
call it that but I'm going to defer to the primary you know the
authoritative body on this the American Psychological Association
okay >> stigmatize trans people but it's not listed as
a mental illness that's a factually incorrect statement to make
it's not in the DSM
>> so in the DSM5 gender dysphoria is listed as a mental
disorder that can arise as a result of extreme stress or distress
that comes comes from one's own gender identity not lining up
with what they were >> you said it's listed as a mental
>> No, no, see the the wording here is very tricky and
important and so it can be diagnosed as a mental disorder, gender
dysphoria specifically and this is not done to stigmatize trans
people. It specifically does not list trans people or non >> aren't
you stigmatizing most mental illness by saying that like oh no
we could call it a mental illness. Are you saying that like we
should be stigmatizing most mental illnesses? Like somebody who's
schizophrenic should actually be stigmatized and feel bad or
isn't that the way you just like totally short circuit Lance
here? You just make Lance like explode like his brain actually
melts down entirely >> nonbinary people as mental. Sorry,
hold on. Why is it stigmatizing to have a mental illness?
>> Let's go. >> It's stigmatizing to say that trans
people or being trans by definition is itself just a mental illness.
This is what right-wingers are consistently >> No, it's
gender. >> Tim P has himself tweeted that out.
>> But being trans is not the same as having gender dysphoria
anyway. It's
>> Oh, he didn't want to press on it. That's too bad. >> But
that's why it's important. Yeah, but it's important to actually
identify these things whether or not they're correct. And again,
it lists >> So, are we that that would be the question.
Are we just cool to like totally like dehumanize or de or like
denigrate people with schizophrenia because it's a mental illness?
Is that fine? or is there just no such thing as a mental illness
or >> experiencing gender dysphoria as a mental disorder?
So that's different than your statement, both statements that
you made so far. >> So I feel like what do you mean every
time I make you guys watch this guy? I've literally never watched
Lance before. I I'm not sure if I maybe I watch Lance for like
the abortion debate highlights with Tim P, but I don't think
I've ever watched another Lance debate before. I can't think
of a single time. >> You told me, "Do you stand by this?"
I said, "Yes." Wait, what what other content has Lance even done?
I can't think of other content Lance has even done other than
the Tim P debate. Maybe I covered that when it happened like
a year and a half ago >> and then you said, "No, you're
wrong." And then you read me something that just echoed back
what I just said. I might need more caffeine, but you got to
explain this to me. >> you're saying it's >> So,
first off, it's not it's not mental illness. It's a mental disorder.
>> I think you're the guy you're the guy who grabs all
the screenshots of Pirate Software and throws them into Chud's
Discord, right? Same guy. Same guy. same guy. I was just going
to say thank you. I used those for content yesterday. Appreciate
it. >> Right. We're distinguishing between those two. And
then secondly, it's it's it's not by definition if you are >> Oh,
not same guy. There's no way you're not the same guy. Why would
two people have the same name? Get the out of here. What do you
mean? That's what what >> trans or if you are non-binary,
you have a mental disorder either because that's not what the
DSM >> No, I know. But that's what the implication of that
sentence and you then doubling down on it means. >> You
asked if if gender dysphoria in the >> I didn't ask anything.
I've read you a quote of yourself that you had said out loud
and I said, "Do you still stand by
>> Even though it's factually incorrect,
>> it's factually incorrect that the DSM5 has a condition
called gender dysphoria. >> See, now you're changing the
topic. It's factually incorrect that they list that they list
it as a mental illness. >> That is not correct. >> You're
saying it's a mental disorder, not a mental illness. I'm not
saying generally that it's a mental disorder. I'm saying if you
experience gender dysphoria, specifically the DSM5 says that
that can be classified as a mental disorder. If you experience
gender dysphoria, extreme distress and duress. >> Yeah.
I don't understand. Sorry. It sounds like we're both saying that
being trans is one thing. >> Keep saying that we're saying
the same thing, but we're not. One one obviously is being utilized
by the right to stigmatize trans people. This is one of the reasons
why people like Tim P will frequently make statements where they
say being trans is a mental illness. It's actually in the DSM5
it says you're mentally ill and stuff like that because they
both think that having a mental illness is something worth of
stigmatization and in addition to that they want to associate
that directly with trans people. So I think furthering that idea
especially coming from again someone like you who is not someone
who identifies as a right-winger a >> he's saying it's
uh it's letting so the rightwing thinks mental illness is is
uh stigmatizing. So, we have to adhere the rightwing's definition
and how they look at it and make sure that we don't let them
call trans people mentally ill. Why is it then okay to let them
call schizophrenic people mentally ill or anything else? Well,
because he's not thinking about anything >> extremist or
any of that kind of stuff. It then gives ammunition. The Tim
can say, "Well, yeah, Jesse Singal said here that the DSM5 says
it's a mental
>> What What do you think the DSM5 says gender dysphoria
is? >> Can we pull up the DSM5 and just read the actual
definitions? I'm I'm extremely You seem like a friendly guy interpersonally,
but I'm very confused right now because I feel like you're yelling
at me and >> you are the most attractive person with Down
syndrome I've ever seen. It's actually insane to me how why are
you so much more attractive than me even though you have Down
syndrome. Can you explain this? You're like a puppy, but you're
also like what is happening? >> And I don't Well, not yelling.
You're not your tone is totally fine. But the >> DSA was
like I don't believe wants this entire thing. But anyways, I'm
going to be I I want to pull it up here so we don't get anything
mixed up. So, it's on table two. The DSM5 criteria for gender
dysphoria are marked in congruence
>> eyes eye twitching. I >> experienced an express
gender and natal gender of at least six month. >> Okay,
we're not looking at the criteria. We're looking at the definition.
Do you think the criteria for schizophrenia is mental illness?
I'm just I'm saying like or schizotiple whatever the I don't
even know if schizophrenia is like a strong diagnosis anymore.
if it's like schizotiple or something. But like dude, do you
think do you think it's mental illness under the character or
under the um criteria? That's so stupid. >> Months in duration
as manifested by at least two of the following. A a marked in
congruence between one's experience expressed gender primary
and or secondary characteristics or in young adolescence the
anticipated secondary characteristics. B a strong desire to be
rid of one's primary and or secondary characteristics because
of a marked in congruence with one's experience in expressed
gender. like he actually doesn't identify that the thing he's
reading is not helpful to the conversation he's trying to have.
There are like people like this.
I hate to bring up the same [__] as my example in
so many cases, so many different cases, but it's like Willy Mack
here right here, right? He can identify that he's he's pulled
something up and it doesn't help his argument at all, but he's
going to read it because it is like a thing that he's seen other
people do. He's like trying to mimic other people and what they
do, right? or in young adolescence or a desire to prevent the
development of the anticipated secondary characteristics. C a
strong desire for the primary and secondary characteristics of
the other gender. D a strong desire to be the other gender or
some affirmative gender different from one's designated gender.
E okay that one that one I don't even that one I don't even know
that you can actually fake. Like I could believe maybe that he's
like an op at some points, but this one okay strong desire to
be treated the other gender or some alternative gender difference
from one assigned gender and an F. The final one. Sorry this
taking a long time. A strong conviction that one's typical feelings
and reactions to other gender or some alternative gender differ
from one's designated gender. So this condition is associated
clinically significant distress or impairment at social, occupational,
or other important areas of functioning. >> So what you
just read, those are the criteria for what? >> For gender
dysphoria.
>> And what is gender dysphoria? >> Do you want me
to reread the entire >> Oh my god.
Jesse's actually disbelief though, too. Jesse's actually in disbelief,
too. Oh my god,
dude. This is actually so much better than I thought it could
possibly be. I didn't realize it would like start cooking right
at the end. I kind of I kind of was like phoning it in at this
point. But holy sh He's like, "Dude, I'm trying to get you to
like read what is this. Just read the definition. Don't be Don't
read me the criteria. Read me the definition. What is it?" The
definition, not the criteria.
>> Dysphoria is what this is what they determine. Again,
again, tend to dysphoria is what they determine, okay, to be
someone who is experiencing distress, duress as a result of having
>> No, no, I know. But, but what but what does it reflect
that is listed in the DSM5? Like, what is >> if you if
you experience gender dysphoria, then that is what is classified
as a mental disorder because they're doing that not to stigmatize
it, but to in order to allow doctors for the ability for them
to diagnose it properly, to be able to help you get medical attention.
So that so that distinction that distinction is very important
and and you keep going back to I think we're saying the same
thing. We're not the the term mental illness is never used at
all in the DSM5 in relation to trans people and also trans being
trans or being non-binary is it not itself a mental disorder
>> experiencing gender dysphoria
>> even donated $3. This is literally no this is Patrick.
Yes, but on multiple different topics in multiple different situations
with different contexts. >> Ain't this the guy that said
he would let a pregnant woman use that he would let a pregnant
woman use meth? No, I believe he said he wouldn't. And then he
said and then when asked why so he was taking the actually abortion
is okay until they're out of the birth canal. Literally within
the birth canal, I support that kind of abortion. And then he
said no, I wouldn't support them smoking meth because that would
be trying them trying to kill a child. So, it's actually significantly
more than saying a nine months pregnant old woman or nine months
nine months pregnant woman, a woman pregnant with a nine-month
old fetus, okay,
can smoke meth. It's more than that. It's more than that. I'm
having a hard time actually putting into words just how dumb
this guy is. It was he was taking the all abortions are okay.
Listen, he's he's broken my brain, okay? He was thinking the
all abortions are fine so long as it's that as long as that child
has not hit escape velocity and exited the vaginal canal. Okay,
that baby can be killed for any reason. And then he was like,
"Oh no, that mom can't smoke meth. That would be a child. That
would be potentially a child."
Hold on, let me honestly just cuz we have more people here now,
I might just watch the clip again. We just watched it, but we
might watch it again. When they are inside of the mother, literally
anything you do to them is acceptable because I want to ask in
good faith. Now you believe that the moment after the child is
outside of the birth canal that they are now endowed with human
rights. Yes. >> However, when they are inside of the mother,
literally anything you do to them is acceptable because they're
inside of the mother. >> Oh, no. I don't think anything
is acceptable, but I think the mother should still have the choice
ultimate uh authority over what happens to her body. >> But
there's a child inside.
What about
>> Uh [__] >> Like should she be allowed
to do meth? >> Yeah. Uh I think if someone is doing meth
while they're pregnant that it is completely acceptable for something
like uh
I don't know what the name of the services in the United States.
>> Child services
would be >> it's her body though. >> Yeah, it's her
body. >> She wants to do meth. What's the big
>> Uh the big deal is that it's she's intentionally trying
to kill the child. >> Can you say that again? >> So
it's not even that he argued. She It's like, "Okay, I guess he
is arguing. She should be able to do meth but also with CPS called
and then why should CPS be called because she's trying to kill
the child, >> but if she just wants to kill that child
intentionally with 100% chance of success, that is okay. >> she's
intentionally trying to kill the >> Hold on there a minute."
>> Yeah. And I see where we're going. Yeah. And I see >> just
He can hear that he himself. He can hear it. He can hear it.
He doesn't know how to handle it.
I don't I don't understand what you're saying. It's her body.
She wants to do meth. What's the problem? >> Well, first
off, doing meth is illegal. Period. Doesn't matter if you're
doing it with a child or without a child.
>> Anyway. Anyway. Huh?
That's what we're dealing with here. Okay. That's what we're
dealing with. Yeah, dude. This guy, I said it. Okay. This guy's
like, this guy's like a gigachad now. Okay. If he stays skinny,
he's like a total gigachad. All he's got to do is stay skinny.
But he may actually be one of the few people who puts significant
work into the content creation space who is like so low IQ that
they can't make politics work despite being hot. Okay. At all.
This guy's put years and years in and he's going to get nothing
out of it because he is just too dumb to argue any of these points.
>> Okay. Do you think gender dysphoria is listed in the
DSM5 as a mental disorder?
uh experiencing gender dysphoria is >> do you think that
um do you think that piranhas are listed in the oh is it film
of ichthod or whatever genus I can't remember you like ask a
qu I need to find something that works better than that I'm trying
to think I can't find anything that works better than that basically
saying
>> the reason the disorders are listed I'm trying to find
a metaphor I don't have to. The reason the metaphors or so the
the diagnosises are listed is because
wait people experience them when you're experiencing the mental
disorder that means you have the mental disorder. What is the
mental what is that mental disorder gender dysphoria? It's a
mental disorder. He's like no no it's not a mental disorder on
its own. When you're experiencing it you're experiencing a mental
disorder. The word game makes no sense. God. We get late in the
stream. My brain just breaks. I My brain is broken. He's broken
my brain. I can't even analogize anymore. Okay, I've lost the
ability to analogize. I can't imagine what other functions by
the end of this I'll be paralyzed. Okay, my brain won't want
to work anymore at all. >> Okay, I'll lose my ability to
breathe. >> Unless I'm confused. >> Well, what's
the difference between a mental disorder and a mental illness?
And we're talking about the symptoms. We're not talking about
being trans.
>> I'm not even defending. I'm just saying it's in the
DSM. you won't you won't >> so so you're saying that it
doesn't matter to you if you call it a mental illness even though
the DSM5 doesn't call it a mental illness because you you don't
see it's a distinction without a difference to you between the
two >> the DSM5 the DSM5 is a list of mental health diagnoses
or mental disorders and one of them one of them is gender dysphoria
in the ICD
they they branched it out and they gave it its own category so
it's no longer um considered a form of mental disorder. I also
like I just got to say as someone with a family history of a
fair amount of mental illness and my own my own uh struggles
like this idea that
let's say mental let's say gender dysphoria is a mental illness
like that doesn't
mean people who have it are any less worthy of
everything they deserve in life. I just I think it's this weird
no one is implying that. I mean that that's
>> a very underhanded tactic to try and get away from the
fact that you were incorrect. Oh, Jesse. Jesse should have cooked
them. Jesse should have cooked them in the exact way I suggested.
Okay. People with schizophrenia, you name some uh some disorder,
right? >> Should those people be treated differently? Should
they be denigrated? Should they be Well, why? I mean, you I assume
you agree that mental illness exists,
right? Does it matter if you change it from calling it a an illness
to a disorder? It's just a word game.
Okay. So, we just shouldn't we should just treat people Yeah.
with mental disorders or mental illnesses or whatever as if they're
people worthy of like uh
like the same happiness, liberty, everything as us. They're like
us. They're like human beings. Even people with mental illnesses
are like human beings, Lance. Okay. >> It's not It's not
about stigmatizing people with mental illness, but it is again
being utilized and weaponized by the right to the far right in
this regard to try and stigmatize trans people. And and this
is yet another example where I think that they can use quotes
that you've said or statements you've made. And again, it's not
coming from a right-winger. It's coming from liberal journalist
Jesse Singal >> as he reads the DSM5, the widely accepted
criteria for mo most mental disorders. Jesse, how dare you read
the DSM5
accurately and allow Republicans to quote you absolutely disgusting
behavior.
you know, was in favor of big public works projects like highways
like the Ottabon and like really investing in public infrastructure.
So, I guess that's bad now because I mean it's just it's a silly
type of argument because >> uh he doesn't even want to
Jesse's too nice to be a debate bro. He doesn't want to cook
Lance. He's like he basically stopped he like he stopped it before
he did the actual thing. >> It can be true that like I
said something I said there's controversy on this issue which
there is. whatever else you think about it, there is controversy.
And a Republican says there's controversy. Like, I don't I don't
know what to tell you. I'm not gonna lie and say there's not
controversy because a Republican might not use it. In the same
way, I'm not going to say public works projects are bad cuz the
worst guy who ever lived was in favor of them. >> Oh, that's
not at all what I accused you of. But I mean, you are aware that
a lot of right-wingers actually have used your own work when
they have attempted. Republicans maliciously quote Jesse so Jesse
shouldn't say accurate statements is what Lance is arguing
>> to both pass bill >> yeah Reuters Reuters journalism
times journalism and my journalism regularly get cited by uh
folks writing legal documents saying that this is controversial
or the evidence is suspect >> I' I've got numerous cases
of federal executive branch reports that have used and cited
your work state legislative materials that have cited and used
your work amicus >> that's because there's a medical there's
a medical controversy here and I think >> but they're specifically
citing your work to justify their right-wing political agendas,
right? And so for me personally, if I was a journalist or >> actually
Smeck day, that's a great point. I think we've if anything, we've
proven that like Lance needs to uh he needs to shut his YouTube
channel down because Republicans continue to use him to make
massive strides on political issues. Okay, not with this clip
specifically, but this went giga viral on Twitter obviously.
Okay, Lance, your existence is forcing rep is like actually keeping
Republicans in office. Okay, you're making them look intelligent
all the time. You should not be allowed to have your YouTube
channel anymore. It's for the good of everybody. All right, it's
for the good of everybody. An author and I was writing and it
was appearing frequently and being used to go after the very
people that I purport to care about, then I would feel that there
was something that I was either missing or I had really up. Right,
dude? Like honestly, if you were like, I care about trans people.
I don't want them to suffer. And then it turns out all of these
right-wingers who tried to pass laws or >> I'm sorry. 99%
of Lance's prep work for this debate went into lighting and book
placement. That's on his own YouTube channel. I don't understand
why after the Lauren Southern debate, this guy still believes
he can debate. This has to be a humiliation fetish.
The whole argument sums up to Jesse. The whole argument sums
up to Jesse. Why are you so obsessed and not writing about the
things I think you should be writing about? Absolutely absurd
argument. This was a hard listen. It's obvious Lance believed
that informed consent model of medicine was the same thing as
informed consent. Really unprepared, really hard to watch at
that point. Um, by the way, I might have made this mistake. I
might have thought like, hey, informed consent is, you know,
the arguments around informed consent and ethics around informed
consent are like, oh, it's hard to inform somebody about medical
issues when they don't have a medical degree because there's
just like a it's can be really complicated to explain a medical
diagnosis to somebody and what they should do for it, right?
And I was like, "Oh, that." So, when he says informed consent
model, I bet that he means like you actually have to inform this
person over time of like what would be best for them. I could
have made that same misunderstanding, but I hope I would have
the foresight and the humility to go, "Oh, the informed consent
model is something different." Jesse, tell me what that is. Or
let's let's look what that is. Let's look up what that is. Sorry.
If you ever watch any creationist, they like to bring up Darwin.
Oh, I didn't. That's uh interesting.
I'm guessing he got a lot wrong when he first proposed his theory.
>> Oh boy. Why does Lance debate like a seventh grader?
You got to do more than just recite a few stats/organizations
that you found after 5 minutes on Google. Why does Lance sound
like he's talking through his teeth? I've heard this one a couple
times now. I've seen this said in chat here while we're watching
this. It hurts my heart that Lance is so cute yet so wrong so
often. He's so
He's so dogmatic. can't see past ideology to understand the harm
that he's causing. You poor you poor dumb beautiful. Okay, it's
up. God was doing a specific and excruciating type of torture
to make me love watching you and hate hearing you speak.
H God. Okay, I can read more comments after. We'll just we'll
just keep watching for a little bit. or all of these cases in
which they're trying to restrict the rights of trans people continuously
cite you because again that way it gives them the validity of
not being able to say this is not just coming from the right
this sure there are some right-wing people who are considered
to be >> so here like again I've not even watched that
much of this debate or that much of like trans debates
>> I'm frequently like not informed enough to have trans
debates cuz it like I didn't get into like Twitch politics until
2022 2023 like late 2022 Maybe even late 2023 now that I think
about it. Might have been late. No, no, no. It was late 2022.
Okay. I didn't even get into politics or Twitch poll like really
until then. And oh no, 2021 maybe 2021. Sorry. But like the trans
debate stuff was almost over. Like it was basically ending. I've
not watched a lot of it, but I did watch Jesse Singal versus
Sam Cedar and Emma Vigland and they made the same critique and
he similarly wipes the floor with he he wipes the floor with
them on that critique.
Right. >> Sam makes the argument. We'll see if uh we'll
see if Surfs if what the is this guy's name? Why did I just lose
his name? The the Surfs guy. We'll see if he actually goes and
makes the same point. I think Sam's point in this was okay. Um
was it Sam Harris wrote an article on torture and that was broadly
used by people to say look the left agrees that this could be
a good thing too, right? Cuz Sam Cedar was arguing oh you should
that's right. Yeah. Sam Ced, sorry, Sam Harris was arguing, oh,
you should be able to torture people if it saves lives, right?
Which is not even a weird thing to say, but then they're like,
"Oh, Republicans use that to win arguments against leftists,
and that was really bad for like the overall culture."
So, that's like probably the best point, which is still stupid,
by the way, because I believe Sam Harris's point wasn't even
like, "Oh, torture is good." It was if torture saves lives, torture
is okay against terrorists. That's the article he wrote. Stop.
He's like, "Stop virtue signaling about this. If torture saves
lives, we should torture terrorists. People who are broadly like
trying to just destroy the West who want to destroy America.
Those people, you can torture them if it saves lives, right?
And I think um that's probably not even a bad thing to say, but
that was Sam Cedar's point. We'll see if Lance makes the same
point. His argument was that it shouldn't be legal, but that
doesn't mean it's wrong in every single situation. Okay. Something
along those lines.
Listen, I didn't I think I read the article back then. I just
didn't read it. And that nullification in court would just play
out. Oh, that like basically, oh, we could leave it illegal and
then if it saves enough lives, there'll be jury nullification.
Oh, okay. Well, I think there's ar there must have been an argument
about the morality, right? That that like torture just can't
broadly be ruled out. Anyway, >> right, but there's also
Jesse. He's a liberal author for for the Atlantic.
>> Well, and the New Yorker and Reuters and the Economist.
>> Absolutely. Even more fuel right there. >> So,
what So, as journalists, what should we do? Should we just say
that this isn't controversial and the evidence is super good?
Cuz >> I wouldn't say I'm not speaking to all journalists.
I'm speaking to you specifically that obviously doesn't that
at all worry you that that again if your work is being cited
by some of the worst individuals to pass laws that are going
to restrict the rights of the very people you pretend to care
about at its core haven't you up >> pretend to care about
a so I I take it you've written about the uh I I will answer
that question but I want to throw one thing back at you. I take
it you've talked on your show about the um the mass graves in
Canada of indigenous
>> Oh, Jesse, that's mean.
weren't having some churches been burned down? Like in the outrage
over that? >> Uh multiple were burned down. Yeah. >> Yeah.
Is that is that >> So, did you watch you watch the Lauren
Southern Saga that I had? Is that why you're invoking this out
of curiosity? No, I I literally picked a Canadian example at
random. But do you feel
>> I don't believe there's no way. There's no way he picked
one at random. Shut the up, dude. Get out of here. >> Also,
do you >> No, I literally picked a Canadian example at
random. But do you feel >> Are you bringing this up because
I'm indigenous? Is that the reason? >> Are you bringing
this up because you watch the Lauren Southern debate? No, I picked
some random Canadian example. I just I picked a Canadian example
at random. You're saying it's because I'm indigenous. Yes. No.
I I just answered why I I He literally just said he picked a
Canadian example at random. Like even if Yeah. Even if he's lying,
he he lied. You're asking another question. He literally just
said his rationale. >> Are you indigenous? >> Yeah,
my mother is.
>> Okay. But do you feel responsible for causing those
churches to be burned
I'm whiter than Lance and I'm
>> indigenous. I I actually am >> for having spoken
on that topic.
>> no, I don't. >> Yeah, because you were telling
the truth or you're telling your understanding of the truth and
some idiots took it too far. That's how life works. And as a
jour Oh no. Oh no. Oh no. Dude, he's one of the POV. You're one
of the idiots who took it too far. Oh no. journalist, you really
have a it's a big part of our job description to say what we
think is true and to not worry too much about what some is going
to do with it. Nothing about the controversy over these treatments
or the fact that we don't really know what the long-term outcomes
is. None of that justifies
hating trans people or the more draconian bands. Like I I just
I wish we didn't live in such a schizophrenic country cuz we're
headed for a landscape where like half the >> Okay, just
so you guys know, Lance got extremely just in case anyone doesn't
know, Lance got extremely worked up about this mass grave controversy
in Canada where they did this underground sonar thing and they
figured out that there was a whole bunch of mass graves outside
of a whole bunch of churches where they had residential schools
they're called, where they used to grab kids off of native reservations,
grab them and force them to enroll these schools so they could
get a Catholic up Catholic or Christian upbringing, right? And
it was an outrage because it was like, "Oh, you didn't care about
these kids." And she buried them all in mass graves. And Lance
was like at the front forefront of that discussion going like,
"Canada's racist. Canada's the worst. We we all these kids. We
we all these kids, right?" And well, people at the time kind
of thought, "Maybe this is trumped up. We haven't really done
this underground technology, this radar technology or whatever,
right? This ground penetrating radar, I think is what it was
called. We haven't really done this. Uh, we should probably chill.
We don't really know what this means." and he had a debate with
Lauren Southern where a bunch of people were still on his side
and he got ass blasted completely and humiliated. So he was on
the way too far out on like Canada needs to apologize. We need
to make amends for this. preparations for this and he got ass
blasted by Lauren Southern in a debate about it and then despite
that or not despite that I shouldn't even say despite that but
now Jesse is bringing it up as an example and he's saying didn't
we have a responsibility as like people who cover this stuff
to be like reasonable about this and just say what the truth
was and Lance was like in a furer over it just totally whipping
up like a frenzy as much as he could so no he probably didn't
feel like he had a responsibility and now Jesse's sitting here
being like hey shouldn't we have Um, shouldn't we be responsible
about this? A furer. A fur furer. Furer. Furer. An outbreak of
public anger or excitement. A wave of enthusiastic admiration.
A craze. >> Furer. Furer.
>> What are you guys What are you guys What are you hearing?
The Get a Get a dictionary, losers.
States will ban these treatments and half the states will just
go the other way and and liberalize it even further. >> there's
truth to the school hiding bodies. No, they literally went and
dug up. They took up like three of the schools where they found
them. Found no bodies, no bones, no nothing. And we're like,
"Oh, we misunderstood what's going on with this ground penetrating
radar." Um, now that doesn't mean, by the way, that doesn't mean
that these schools weren't massive abuses of power, massive overreaches,
uh, that sort of fly in the face of all we think about human
rights today. They're really bad. They're really evil. Lots of
Native kids died in these schools. Lots of native kids got beaten.
Got like the And to begin with, it was like a something of a
cultural something. I try to hesitate because I don't know as
much about it as I probably should as somebody who's like lives
in this country, but like it was a cultural genocide. It was
attempting basically it was the idea that politicians of Canada
went down to the States and the states they were like, "Yeah,
these people if you let their kids grow up in on these reservations,
they will be savages. They will never be able to learn anything.
They'll lose the capacity to do math or speak English or speak
any language. They'll just be savages." Right? So, you have to
take them off of these reservations because if you don't do that,
you're actually damning them to a life of like idiocy. they'll
be like completely inept in every way. And and so they took all
these kids away from their parents and they put them in these
schools, these boarding schools, and people starved to death.
There was famine. There was disease. It was very bad.
>> Simply substance. Thank you for the 12 months. Let's
go. Damn. A whole year of content is crazy, chat. And the most
important lesson I learned is Han is bad. Damn.
Okay, so I just needed to do all of that to say, hey, the residential
schools were really bad, but probably not bad enough that they
were doing mini holocausts all across them. Okay, probably not
quite that bad. We can we could just say they were really bad
with the abuse, the the famine, the taking kids away from their
parents, the cultural genocide. That's probably all enough to
call them bad and like and denounce them and apologize for them,
right? We don't need like many holocausts across all of the country
as well. It's probably >> your I think your claim that
if if you make a true claim and then someone somewhere does something
on the basis of it, that's your fault. I just don't buy that.
I think the church example is what I'm getting at. >> But
so for your example to work, I would have had to have been first
lying about the fact that there were, you know, children who
were
>> at the resial schools. >> Well, there are examples
there. There are times when you've actually publicly stated,
like you tweeted out, "I done goofed. I got the data wrong. I
I I I
>> uh this is dirty, but I think it's important for those
following this debate. Everyone, myself included, has been misreading
the single biggest study on childhood gender dysphoria, desistence,
and persistence."
Yeah, but hold on. There's no way.
Please, for the love of God, for Lance's sake, for the sake of
Lance's career, do not be an example where this misreading was
in favor of trans rights and in favor of like youth gender medicine.
And now that he's reading it correctly, it's um it's like actually
working against Lance's argument cuz that would be could you
imagine how embarrassing that would be? And I feel like Lance
is dumb enough to to bring this up and then put this up on screen
and have that be the case. actually misinterpreted a study like
that that you you've publicly said that >> so that was
li that was lying. So whether you were doing it because you wanted
to, whether you were doing it because again you misinterpreted
the data, the end results will be the same, >> Yeah. But
you're accusing him of lying, which is a crime of intent >> at
the end of the day. Like like I if I pull up here, okay, maybe
spec >> I believe his point is that like other people other
people including medical professionals were misreading the study
as well. >> Examples is more fair, right? So I don't put
words in your mouth, but the the article you wrote uh specifically
stating that most people don't understand the rates of which
uh this okay you the study that shows that I think it's 80% or
70%. Sorry I want to pull up the study itself and I know you
you've not have a lot of time left. Um
just see
okay um the study that shows researchers found puberty blockers
and hormones didn't improve trans kids mental health at their
clinic and then they published a study claiming the >> So
this is a critique of Tordolf AL 2022 uh up on your Substack
correct?
So in this study, and please correct me if I'm wrong, maybe I'm
also misinterpreting the data, but I have the table in front
of me. They have what is a baseline, a three-month, a six-month,
and a n a 12-month uh category where they're obviously interviewing
adolescence who both are put on puberty blockers and gender affirming
hormones, and then adolescence who are put on none. And your
assertion is that the difference between the moderate to severe
depression, which in the baseline is 57%
and the 12-month period is 56%
shows little to no uh change effectively and that it's disingenuous
for them to have said that the idea of using puberty blockers
or gender affirming care has benefits as as a result uh because
it just shows such a small amount of change to their moderate
to severe depression. Is that fair? moderate to severe depression
goes from
sorry 59
>> um 57% with I would assume the article or sorry the
argument would be
that with no treatment they go from 59% to 83% which I guess
is what I that might not be very tangible because you have so
many people drop off it looks like wait hold on prevalence of
outcomes 792 why does this flip what's what's going on here that
this flips like this there's seven versus 92 too.
Oh, they had seven people come in. No, no, never mind. We should
go from here. Why does this go up to 59? It just be like they
didn't have everybody respond.
That's weird. That's weird. Anyway,
>> it So, there's 57% at the baseline.
>> Wait, it doesn't improve though, right? Outcomes. No,
like as in I think it actually goes down slightly. There's no
improvement shown technically with no no
it actually goes up. But again, so many >> and then it
goes in 12 months to 56%. And so that 1% change is really what
I think in this article you've kind of grasped on to to say that
this is a disingenuous article. Um or sorry, a disingenuous study
because it's not really showing a market improvement, right?
Which >> I would imagine that the drop off rates are actually
his big problem with this study. You >> know, 57 to 56%
I'll grant you does not seem like an overwhelmingly huge change
after 12 months of being on puberty blockers and gender affirming
care.
Yeah. So, you're saying what? Sorry, what are you saying I'm
lying about? Or >> Well, you're misrepresenting what the
stud is supposed to indicate because there's a baseline between
people who are on puberty blockers and gender affirming uh hormones
and then there's people who are on nothing and that the people
who are on nothing that goes from 59% for moderate to severe
depression to 83%
after the 12 months. >> Moderate to severe depression,
none at baseline is 59%.
Then at none,
there's five kids left. It's the sample's gone from 54 kids to
five kids, do you think? >> Right. And in both directions,
the sample size has actually increase for the kids who are on
puberty blockers. It goes from four to 32. >> Kids shift
kids shift over time. But but can you com like you said 59% to
83%. I'll include this table in the show >> Yeah, please.
>> You can't you know that you can't say
compare percentages of a group of 54 kids to a group of five
kids. >> I agree. And and my
>> Oh, look. It's like the Wait, hold on. So my point here,
>> wait, he's agreeing now. Hold on. >> Is is not
at all that there are problems with their methodology or that
again I I would also like to know a lot more information about
the study. I'd like to know how did you determine uh for example
what you consider to be severe depression? Uh was it a ranking
scale uh based on a other uh you know test that have been on
the past something to that I I'm not here to argue that in the
12-month period, the five uh kids who reported 83% right uh is
in some way that this is ironclad. This this shows without shadow
of a doubt kids who are not put on uh you know puberty blockers
and hormones have much worse outcomes.
But that is what the data is supposed to indicate from the study,
right? is is that if you are on a baseline, and you even say
this a couple paragraphs down, that hey, if the study is trying
to show ultimately that if you're on a baseline, even if it doesn't
improve your quality of life, that's better than not being on
it at all, but that's unfair
essentially, right? >> Well, but we don't but we don't
know that from this study. >> It's a very different territory.
Hold on. Was there another thing that he brought up? It's comes
not from the kids in the treatment group getting better, but
rather the kids in the comparison group getting worse. This brings
us into very different territory medicine-wise. Sure, there are
some contexts where merely keeping someone stable might be considered
a good outcome. If you give someone with stage four cancer a
drug and it keeps their tumors the same size for many months
or even years, that's often a win. If you give an Alzheimer's
patients a drug, Alzheimer's patient a drug and it arrests their
neurokcognitive decline for protracted period, that would be
a win. I don't think we even have any drugs like this.
That would be during the the what do you call it? The um controversy
around that big Alzheimer's drugs. Alzheimer drugs. Alzheimer's
drug. God damn it.
But this point of puberty blockers and especially hormones is
to make kids better. And they didn't get better in this study.
I'm not saying that improvement in a treatment group is necessary
and sufficient for claiming a treatment works. You also need
a control or a comparison group. Click the footnote for a brief
explanation of what I mean here if this confuses you at all.
But if you give someone medicine to treat something and their
symptom doesn't improve, shouldn't that cause you to question
whether the treatment works?
Okay.
So, he's saying basically if you if you lose all of your people
in your baseline with no treatment, then realistically you can't
say your treatment works, right? You don't have a good you don't
have a good uh placebo group or whatever >> at all. >> It
wouldn't be a placebo group actually because technically you're
not giving them puberty blockers with no medicine. It would just
be a baseline. I don't know why I used a different thing. >> Fair.
Essentially, right? But we don't but we don't know that from
this study because all the kids basically all the kids who hadn't
yet started hormones dropped out of the study and we don't know
what happened to them. Like so that's why we only have >> six
kids left in the no hormones cohort 12 months out. So this all
this means is like we we don't know. And what happened was they
initially put out press releases saying kids got better after
I pointed out to them this out to them. They they corrected their
seem to be agreeing with me that they
So in in this regard, this this is not the way that you would
treat uh the potential positive outcomes for other medications,
right? There's a lot of other medications where the um improvement
rate say for someone like put on SSRIs or anti-depressants may
simply stabilize them and then people who are not on a uh medication.
>> But isn't there like actually a controversy around SSRIs
where it's like we don't even know that these actually improve
people? Like it might just be throwing darts. Like it probably
does improve some people, but it's like, oh, it's a thing you
can do and maybe it helps, but maybe it doesn't. It's not like
we're actually we're not curing depression over here. We're just
throwing stuff at the wall seeing if something sick >> at
all have much worse outcomes. That that can absolutely be the
case, right? Which is what which is what I believe was the purpose
behind this as flawed as it could be. But to to offiscate that
factor to not point out that that is >> they're better
than placebo. No, I do not believe SSRIs are better than I don't
think they're necessarily better than placebo for reducing depression
long term. Am I crazy? I think that's like something they've
come to after years and years and years of of prescribing them
is they are not actually SSRIs were first option then they got
moved to second after exercise and diet.
Wait, what Finland study addressed this difference and why there's
a dropout rate within studies. So yeah, very strong comparison
between the two in terms of people the kids who are not on anything
for example would have higher rates. Here's Queenman live. Thank
you for the raid 100 viewers. What's up? What's up? What's up
guys? If you didn't watch this Lance debate, you got to go find
somebody to watch it through. This is actually some of the best
content I've seen like debate content I've seen in a while. Lance
is a magician. We actually need to keep funding Lance. Okay,
everybody needs to keep funding Lance if you don't care about
American politics. Okay, keep funding Lance if you don't care
about politics. If you just want to watch the world burn, because
the content is fantastic every single time, okay, it is awesome
watching this guy be a complete and utter and and spill his spaghetti
all over himself all the time. It's
is absolutely disastrous for any leftwing cause, but if you just
like watching somebody be a on the internet, few people can do
it better. All right. >> Here's where I think things get
a little bit more complicated, though, because you only focused
on the 57% to the 56%, right? Which is again a 1 percentage point,
which you say is statistically insignificant.
In the moderate to severe anxiety at the baseline, it's 57%
that goes down to 51%.
So again, >> what's the sample size when it's what's the
sample size? >> It's four when it starts at the baseline.
And so more kids then join in every other group. at 3 months
23 join at 6 months 28 join and at 12 months 29 join. So >> I
know but these like these are statistically meaningless comparisons
because if you go from four kids to 29 kids you can't you can't
just do a percentage comparison then that's like the whole problem
with this study. Um this is like one of the worst studies published
on this subject in terms of all the problems with it. The their
inability to answer basic follow-up questions. I consulted a
statistician who said this is not the right method to use. So,
I would just argue this isn't the hill to die on, but it doesn't
really matter what it's not a hill choosing to die on. In fact,
there's parts of the article that you wrote that I would actually
agree with. It's the fact that again, I think you're trying to
you're trying to Well, no, I think you're trying to cherrypick
specific information because it all obviously is going to benefit
or help your narrative, right? And in the case of uh you know
your statements saying that the kids who got uh worse as a result
of not being on on medication
um you you say well like yeah there could be other examples of
medications where we do this and that that could be beneficial.
There's a breath of medications in which we do that and that's
actually you know a large part of so much um of how we treat
kids with ADHD, antiscychotics, antibiotics, SSRI.
>> So my response my response to this would be that um
for years a lot of uh advocates for youth gender medicine were
saying that puberty blockers will make kids feel better not that
it will stabilize them. So if you look at the research protocol
for this $10 million study that's very a lot of controversy in
the states led by Joanna Olsen Kennedy that's the same woman
I wrote about in the economist uh when she got sued she hypothesized
in her research protocol puberty blockers will improve kids mental
health. So to me if a scientist says we think it's going to improve
mental health it's definitely fair game to point out when it
doesn't. Now, what the point I was getting at, and I think I'm
being transparent here, >> but but in this case, it does.
Even though I agree with you, you can't compare four kids to
36 kids and accurately say this study is indicative of the totality
of this topic. But in this specific study, even flawed, it's
it's it's incorrect to state that stabilizing a child rather
than simply improving their quality of life and then kids that
are on nothing becoming decidedly effectively way worse
is. But we don't but we don't know that happened because the
vast majority of kids >> So that so that's what you pointed
out not not that it invalidates the very concept of being on
puberty blockers or gender affirming hormones itself could potentially
make kids not spiral into more depression or not spiral into
more cuz that would be a benefit then right wouldn't you agree
if that was the case between those two
>> dude I
there's so many things to say right now and just none of them
very toss friendly. I >> of course but this is such a weak
study we just we don't know what happened to the kids cuz they
all like so many of them dropped out. So I think if you look
at this table >> um I think most folks and I'm I'm not
particularly quantitative challenged pretty basic issues. I think
when you lose that much of your sample >> uh you can't
really say anything about how these kids were doing 12 months
out. You also can't compare the kids who took hormones to the
kids who didn't without controlling for the potential differences
between them because the kids who aren't on hormones
might not be on hormones because they have worse mental health
and need to be stabilized first. So I just yeah I just I think
this is a really bad study but I'm I'm >> bad study but
I I'm wanted to use an example of exactly why I think that specifically
cherrypicking elements of it while also like it would be fine
if you just pointed out that those specific
>> you can't I mean the you can't just cherrypick elements
of it. No, my criticism is that it's cherrypicking elements of
its own data set and like it's actually not not well founded,
not well um the the model or the statistical
uh what would you call it? The statistical design of design of
their study is just like totally worthless >> of the study
were themselves incorrect. But then why not go one step further
and say that like now there's multiple studies that overwhelmingly
demonstrate that children who are on puberty blockers or on put
on hormones who are gender dysphoric have amazing outcomes. There's
green and >> that would be that would be lying on my part
to say that >> green anal 2021 uh sample size 11,914
uh 13 to 24 year olds showed uh depression lowered 27% uh 39%
under 18 suicidality change >> that was Jack that was Jack
Turban study >> this is green uh lowered 26 overall 38
under 18 uh there's the 2023 study chen uh that one had 30 33
uh Sorry, 315 kids. Uh they lowered 1.47
a year on the depression scale, which again is fantastic. You
know, devise the older one. Sorry. >> 1 1.47 out of how
many? >> Uh I have to open up the specific >> Okay.
So, you said it was f you said
1447, which is fantastic without knowing what scale you're referencing.
>> See, you're doing the exact same thing you're doing
before where it's like you have to >> Dude, how do you
not milk surf content for four hours? How do you not do it? It's
just too much. There's too much here, you know,
>> to discount the totality of the study by cherrypicking
a thing where it's like, see, Lance, you didn't actually know
this one thing, so you're a fool. And it's like, that's why I
would
[__]
>> I don't want to I don't want to just, you know,
laugh. This guy's just like,
>> this guy's just winning, unfortunately.
>> Do I read this? I don't know.
I I'm not going to read that tweet. Never mind. Never mind. >> I
am a fool. But also that's >> I am going to read that tweet.
>> Worst terrorists of the 21st century. Osama bin Laden
did 911. Muhammad Siddi Khan did London bombings. Denims did
CPS. Bad Empanada did CPS. Ham did CPS. Noah Samson did CPS.
Shadow Vumador did CPS. H3 Stark did CPS. Shredder cheese did
CPS. Is this just a reference to the dog? Jesus. Like, I'm sorry.
Yes, we've we've managed to transfer the crime of doing CPS onto
it's literally it's just a rock, right? 9/11 happened and they're
like, you know what? We're going to hold every single Arab in
the Middle East responsible for this, the US. And CPS happened
and they're like, you know what? We're going to hold every leftist
content creator on the internet responsible for this. Good lord.
>> That's why I say I have to defer to the broad consensus
of the scientific community. and the broad consensus of the scientific
community on on this on on this topic, right? Because I I I'm
not a scientist and I'm not a data analyst. I Jesse, so that's
why I'm >> why why don't we defer to the fact that again
every single major medical association in Canada agrees upon
the >> it's a Starker and uh Starker changed their name
to Shredder Cheese and Ethan lost it. Okay? >> Like rather
than going, "Well, Lance, you don't understand how the study
works. Lance, you you don't understand how this one element works."
That that'd be really easy to to pick holes. If if you were to
tell me, Lance,
>> if you don't like that, then stop referencing studies,
Lance. He keeps referencing these studies and then making arguments
about Jesse's arguments in the studies. Then he goes, but I'm
not a not an expert. I'm not an expert, guys. Okay, why did you
start this entire argument? What are we doing?
>> Explain to me what exactly the, you know, the plus minus
change of this particular volume of children means. I'm going
to get that wrong because again I'm not a data analyst or the
scientist making the study, right? I I have to reflexively be
like but it does seem if you were to have curiosity on this topic
and not want to push an agenda that this is overwhelming in terms
of the amount of evidence that comes out in >> the single
best way we have to make the argument you're making is known
as a systematic review. And all the systematic reviews say that
these studies are quite weak and very prone to bias. So, I just
don't know how as a science journalist I'm supposed to ignore
that fact and just list off. >> So, if the sentence you
just said was incorrect, if there are systematic reviews that
contest that, which I'm going to have to I know you're you're
wanting to go, but if I could bring that up and >> gender
affirming hormone therapy was consistently found to reduce depressive
symptoms and psychological distress.
Evidence for quality of life was inconsistent with some trends
suggesting improvement. There was some evidence of effective
changes differing for those on masculiz masculineizing versus
feminizing hormone therapy. Results for selfmastery effects were
ambiguous.
Where's uh puberty blockers here? I don't see puberty blockers.
I I mean I'm assuming they will they will differentiate between
gender hormone gender affirming hormone therapy versus puberty
blocking. Right.
>> There was some trans >> and sent you a link of
a systematic review that actually contests directly what you
just said. Would you revert your position on this? >> If
there if on top of the
>> four or five that say there's not evidence, there was
one that says there is evidence. >> You you asked for a
systematic review. A systematic review is going to be comprehensive.
Correct. It's it's going to include multiple conducted. >> Okay.
So, if if I can if we can find one and I can send that to you,
would you change your position on this topic? >> I would
read it. I I know there's one conducted by team I think in Texas
that claimed that the evidence was good. But it all depends on
in much the same way. I don't really care what the AMA says until
I've dug into it and read what it says. Like the systematic reviews
have to be conducted well. But yeah, if there's a systematic
review, I would say that it's losing significantly to all the
systematic reviews saying we don't know about these treatments.
But yeah, that if it's well conducted, that would nudge my views
in your direction for >> Okay. The the other question I
would have then is is for like for preventative or like stabilizing
or what do you call it maintenance like maintenance based medications
medications that you would be taking for a prolonged period of
time in order to try and stabilize children. Once again, it's
something that you've only focused on when it it's related to
trans people, whereas again there's a lot of other topics where
we do this, right? Like
which affects millions of kids, uh ADHD medication, which again
affects millions, antiscychotics,
which which are
so I'm guessing for most of these the answer will be while the
medical research is far better and far better supports like a
lot of these things, you could maybe go into SSRIs for kids.
I'm sure Jesse's got some opinions on SSRIs for kids. He might
have even written articles about it. I wouldn't be shocked. But
it's like nowhere else is the science this bad and the political
discussion so far away from the science. That's the issue is
the the delta between like what is being advocated for by professional
organizations versus what the research suggests. That's why this
is a big deal. >> Hundreds of thousands
>> examples of big of big medical controversies that a
lot of journalists have written about. I agree. Uh well, why
isn't that your primary focus when it affects way more children
and it happens to be medications they have to take for prolonged
periods of time that have very negative outcomes? Like why why
would you focus primarily on medications children take that only
affect a couple hundred to potentially a thousand children a
year when when a lot of these other topics
>> a thousand? Yeah, sure. I don't buy the a thousand estimate
um cuz those are all have been written about a ton like antibiotic
resistance whether we're prescribing too much ADHD medication.
I think in some cases there's interesting parallels to this debate
especially with things like this is far from the only situation
where sometimes a kid walks into a doctor's office and is medicated
right away. That's a broader problem. So in my book I'm trying
to point out this isn't its own controversy but it gets to sort
of more structural problems with the American medical system.
I do have to go before we go. Um, just to maybe encourage other
listeners to do the same thing, what was our what was our agreement?
Was it Palestinian Children's Relief Fund agree? >> Oh.
Oh,
Lance presented this in a totally different way. Lance was just
mad.
Lance said that Jesse knew for a fact that they didn't have an
agreement on this and that he was really caught off guard by
this at the end of the debate. He like addresses it at the beginning.
Sounds like Jesse just totally is like an aloof because he wasn't
ready to be on camera and like wasn't ready for this debate overall.
He dominated it. >> Uh, sure. Absolutely. >> Okay.
Yeah. Uh, I had to lure
this. I enjoyed this conversation despite our disagreement, but
we did I did lure you here by saying we would both donate to
that cause, which I think we're both very happy to do. Um, I'm
happy to talk again at some point, but >> would you be
comfortable donating to the UNRWA? I ran the 5K and I I raised
thousands of dollars for them a few years ago. I just I think
Palestinian Children's Relief Fund I'm more confident in their
administration that it'll go straight to like the neediest cases.
So, that's my preference. >> Well, yeah, you did. I actually
didn't even know that you had written uh as a call to uh bringing
me on the show uh until someone pointed it out that you had actually
Were you tweeting or or skiing on on the blue sky related to
this topic? I think I tweeted and I I think I >> No one
enjoyed this combo. Wrong. Spudgun. Wrong. Wrong. This combo
is tremendously entertaining.
>> I don't remember. Uh but I just >> I mean it.
>> There's no way you just said >> did and I I think
I exed and I skeded. I don't remember. Uh but I just >> Why?
Why? >> I mean it was probably something I was going to
do anyway. I did it earlier this summer. But I do I think it's
important to have these conversations uh out in the open and
I appreciate they did it. Well, thank you for having me and thank
you for answering a lot of my difficult questions, Jesse. >> It
was a pleasure. Uh, I will stop recording. Okay. So, it'll >> The
recording has stopped.
>> I'm sorry. I have I was supposed to be my friends for
dinner in DC since uh 15 minutes ago. If you could send me your
half when you're >> The recording has stopped. >> You
get a chance um >> It'll it'll Yeah. Uh or Google Drive
or whatever. But um yeah, I'm happy to talk more about this at
some point. I just I I think I would my parting words offline,
Mike, would just be like the question of who you defer to and
who you're skeptical of. I don't I don't think you're consistent
about it. But I think you probably think the same thing about
me. But uh I'm glad we had >> I I think if you're a person
who claims to be like a person of science, I think we both do,
right? Like I'm I love science. I >> That's what I think
when I see Lance,
there goes a man of science. >> I think science is awesome
and I I love the scientific method and I love inquiry. I I think
that why would you like you're effectively making in the trans
debate the same debate that anti-climate scientists make for
the 3% when it's like there's a 97% consensus amongst the scientific
community that climate change is real anthropomorphic climate
change but then why focus on the three then and why don't I think
if you read more of myself you'll see I think a lot of these
studies are just there's a lot of terrible studies and I wrote
about terrible studies way before I wrote about trans terrible
>> studies there there's terrible studies on climate science
but And of again that
>> Like why focus? >> I just think it's Yeah, I get
what you're saying. Um let's >> Wow. Wow.
Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow.
Wow. Wow. All right. We got what? 20 minutes left.